Boom,
and we're live den.
Yeah.
Leibow [inaudible] the man with the most
beautiful accent in the world.
It just thread the itunes reviews saying
it's kind of who we are really sending
to these guy describing this horror
story with the accent from it sound like
it's making your pizza while historian
and therefore they don't know is I am
making the pizza while I'm talking that
here's what's happening.
Yeah.
And if they could see you,
you look like a professor that was
kidnapped by a biker gang for forced to
Kim's in here with this red brotherhood
jacket on this leather jacket from these
native Americans with this big red fist
on it.
He's got a Bandana on you.
You're just,
you're missing a motorcycle.
It's all you're missing,
right?
That's uh,
that's the next.
You could be in like some easy rider
type movie,
right?
I could see it.
It just carrying a shotgun til I dance.
So,
uh,
are you digging doing this podcast?
Are you kidding me?
On Fire?
Oh Man.
I'm loving it.
I'm having fun.
Well,
let's put it that way.
I love doing it.
It's a royal pain in the ass.
The research cause well your podcasts,
much like Dan Carlin's is very
different.
I always feel ashamed calling my podcast
a podcast cause it's just you sit down
and talk,
but yours is like,
it's an audio lesson on history and in
depth audio lesson on like very extreme
aspects of history.
Yeah.
It gets and you know that part I enjoy
because the storytelling part is
awesome.
You got a penis story and make it
[inaudible] connected with pop culture.
Do something that's fun.
That's the part that I love is the month
prior to that of just brutal research.
Just call them been through boring
historical book after boring historical
books to find those little nuggets that
are amazing.
Yeah.
And then spin it into a narrative that's
the power deck gets a lethal old
sometimes where you're like,
man I do I really need to read 200 hours
of stuff for this one thing.
It's like that's a lot.
Yeah.
I can only imagine now when you do that,
when you're going over,
combing over all these different uh,
history books and all these different
papers written on various times,
do you,
are you like extracting chunks and like
putting them in Microsoft word and then
going over it and then like how did you
form it?
Well,
the question is kind of like do form it
as a script or how much of it,
so everything is completely written out.
Not exactly because otherwise then it
sound like it sound like yard guy.
You're getting a seeing and gets boring,
but it doesn't sound right.
I just take super extensive notes,
kind of like if you are to give a
lecture that you have never given,
you're not gonna sit down and read it by
you are going to,
you know,
you have something to keep you on track
to make sure it's like,
oh,
where am I going next?
Okay,
great.
There's nothing.
So it's a as detailed as possible
without turning a team to a dry guy or
he Denise Page type of stuff.
Yeah,
I mean history is such a fucking awesome
subject because people are crazy and
throughout history people have done so
many crazy things and it's just,
it's,
it's
such a great thing to know like when
you,
if you only had today,
like if we only had our current era and
we're looking around how fucking
maniacal people are,
how crazy the world is.
We were like,
God,
how'd this happen?
How did we get here?
And then you just listen to your podcast
and you go,
oh,
this shit's been going on forever now.
Seriously.
This is the good tosh.
Yes,
exactly.
It is in case you are welcoming,
she's good times and yes,
there's much to complain about and yes,
there's much we can do better without a
doubt,
ladies and gentlemen,
but this is as fucking good as it's ever
been by far.
The human psyche is a very weird place
because there's so much amazing stuff
that human beings don't are just so much
and vendors,
the amount of horror that can be
unleashed throughout that has been
unleashed throughout history by people
against other people.
Is it just insane?
Yeah.
What is like when you go back and you,
you go over history,
what is the most confusing or disturbing
era?
He,
I to me is not so much at Bharti Kohler
period because the same bathrooms and
merge a lot of the times at different
point in time,
ease is more,
it was moments,
you know,
when,
uh,
when mob mentality takes over because
the reality is the average person is
not,
I don't have the award of view where I
think the average person is evil.
I don't think that,
I think the average person is weak,
which means that when a inequity nations
where everybody's pushing in one
direction is very easy to jump on the
bandwagon and in some cases then a very
ordinary human being can do horrible
actions.
You meet them for dinner and you think
pleasant person good enough,
but you put them in the wrong context.
And devotee scene turns to shit I just
did.
Um,
I just finished right now it is to
perceive it is less,
probably the most disturbing.
I now I want to what podcast about
flowers and puppies because this one was
heavy.
Man,
I need this [inaudible] kind of compare
and contrast on the sand creek massacre
of the Cheyenne in Colorado in the 1860s
and then me lie in Vietnam in 1968 and
actually they split it because I had id
the sand creek and they had,
um,
this guy,
Daryl Cooper was the martyrmade podcast
is an amazing podcast or,
and he covered me lie and dining.
The third APP is,
or we're going to sit down and kind of
chat about what does this all mean about
the human nature.
Why do the reason why that particular
story in those two stories,
interest means because it's um,
too brutal massacre of civilians,
but in both cases that are solely or
should refuse to participate or actually
try to stop it.
They're not the majority there and
minority,
but they are there and they try.
So it's not just a story of people doing
ugly stuff.
It's like,
what is that make one guy when all
their,
hey go shoot that three year old,
the one guy goes,
yes sir,
and does it and the next guy goes,
no,
that's not what we are.
Screw you.
I'm not doing that.
That's what interests me is like the
individual element.
What make people in the exact same
circumstances.
One person go down a really dark path
than somebody else instead of having the
balls to say no,
that's not what I am.
That's not what we do with the native
American masker.
What,
who was,
how many people were the ones that
refused?
Cause you never hear about that.
Oh you hear about it's the horrific
actions of the soldiers and which was
the majority.
But there was also like,
there was this one guy,
um,
what's the guy who named Sila Sila soul.
He was told about the guy with balls of
fire and cause the guy,
he and the capital of other officers or
refuse to let the man and them,
cause they were divided in different
companies.
So their companies,
they say no or not participating in
this.
This is just straight up slow.
They're these guys that are not even a
real targets.
These are a bunch of civilians.
So day or a fuse.
And then a silas sold testified against
his commander at the inquiry and,
and he was promptly murder shortly after
noon.
So he's like,
it's a crazy story,
but still to this day that are people
from the Cheyenne tribe who every year
they have a ceremony for Silas soul
because they say,
I need not being for him.
A lot more of us would have died on that
day.
And he did that really brave thing and
paid the price for it.
So you know,
if you're looking for heroism,
you can do a lot worse.
Don't look at this guy story because
that guy was seriously,
you know,
stand up for his conviction on their
most extreme circumstances.
So it kind of top of,
I admire that dad had to be incredibly
difficult to just imagine what those
people were doing.
I mean,
when you hear some of the accounts of
the slaughters of native Americans,
it's just terrifying that people can
just look at someone and just decide,
that's not a person or that's not us.
This is the other.
They've got to be eliminated.
So we're just going to kill all these
kids and kill all these women.
And it's happened all over the country.
I mean there's,
there's two things that happened to
native Americans.
One,
the big one is disease.
Sure.
And wasn't on purpose.
There's this big myth that people put,
like they put smallpox and blankets and
that's all bullshit,
right?
It's pretty much been proven that they
didn't really understand bacteria or
diseases.
There's one story that's a possible is
not a proven thing during,
cause initially nobody understood
bacteria and these or the first hand
that plessy are completely
unintentional.
There's one tale about the French and
Indian war where during a break,
the Bdt Shar talking about it saying one
of the commander saying,
Hey,
maybe we should give them some blankets
from the smallpox hospital.
You know,
while we do know that he suggested it,
we have no proof whatsoever that he was
actually done.
So.
So that's probably how the rumor got
started,
right.
Problem.
But in most cases would happen is just
that the Europeans came over and just
inadvertently introduced native
Americans diseases and 90% of them were
wiped out.
Yeah.
That's a crazy number.
If you really stop to think about it,
it's going to see they're probably the
most dramatic demographic disaster in
human history because you know,
I've never,
before you had a,
where a whole
continent was not exposed to a series of
diseases.
And so of course there's no immunity the
first time they're exposed.
They,
you know,
you don't need to even have smallpox of
Cannes needs on somebody and the next
day,
half of the villages that,
you know,
yeah,
that's crazy.
It's just,
it's amazing that if,
uh,
a group of people just has not come in
contact with something that other people
come in contact with all the time and
just God with you got a cold,
you'd be fine.
Just have some chicken soup,
take a nap.
Meanwhile,
these people are just dead.
That's pretty sales them off.
That's probably why aliens don't show
up.
It's like those motherfuckers are dirty.
If maybe show up these needle nose and
we will,
our whole planet will die.
Or maybe the opposite.
They know they'll kill us.
Maybe they have like some super advanced
diseases.
That's the other posts to be.
Yeah,
I guess it's just a immune system thing,
right?
If your immune system is not prepared
for it.
So it is,
there's a great book by a guy named Dan
Flores.
Um,
well he wrote two,
but one of them actually,
actually it was a paper that he wrote
about the buffalo and he saying that
it's really interesting because he
compares the initial and counters that
European settlers had and European
travelers had,
um,
before the native Americans were wiped
out.
And they talk about how many animals
were on the planes and they make it a
direct account of it.
And then after the Europeans had come
in,
90% of the native Americans had been
wiped out.
And that's when the buffalo population
increased goes through the roof and
you're seeing these gigantic packs of
mill wouldn't be packed.
So it hurts,
I guess,
of millions and millions of Buffalo.
And he said that's directly attributed
to the lack of predators,
which means lack of native Americans
because they were preying on these
buffalo,
of course.
Really interesting.
Yeah.
That guy,
you had him on the podcast ones,
right?
Yeah,
I get them on again.
I love that guy.
That was awesome.
Book,
Coyote America Dumbo.
That book changed the way I feel about
coyotes.
Yep.
I used to be like,
fuck,
those little rats will run them over and
now I'm like those little wolves and
they're pretty bad ass.
Yeah.
That was a great type.
Is that I enjoyed that one.
Yeah.
Did they're so gangster.
One just stared me down the other day.
I stopped my fucking car and uh,
just,
you know,
because he was in,
it was a kind of a,
not a lot of people in this area.
It was,
it was fairly late at night and he was
on this road of someone just pull over
and just see what this coyote does and
he just fuck it stood like 30 feet from
my car just staring at me,
just staring at me.
That's bad ass.
Right.
They're just like,
whatever,
dude,
what are you going to do?
I'm about to run into these woods.
You never get to see me again or I'll
stick around.
Maybe if you fuck up,
I'll eat you.
Right.
I'm just trying to figure out what to do
right here.
Those guys don't mess around.
That's crazy that they just can live and
be completely embedded in our society.
Like there we had a biologist,
what was the gentleman's name that we
had from the Department of Parks and
services?
See if we find this guy.
But um,
he's actually a biologist who tracks
coyotes and uh,
he tracks them all over the state and
even tracks mountain lions.
They tag them and put those collars on
them and stuff.
Uh,
but he said that there's a pack of
coyotes.
It lives in downtown La.
Then I believe it in the heat of
everything,
they found some abandoned building and
they dented up in this abandoned
building and that's where they live.
Like how those guys that are resilient,
they thrive in anything.
They thrive.
Yeah.
You're like crazy animal stories.
So check this out about it.
[inaudible] there's,
my mom went for a walk with their dog
and their dog is a big mean dog,
right?
So they are walking in,
they see ahead of them and he's lethal.
Garp early 10 years old with this tiny
little five pound dog type of thing.
And there's a coyote maybe like 20 yards
behind there that's clearly stalking
them.
And the garden didn't see it.
And he's obviously aiming for the five
pounder and his just,
and so my mom yelled at,
they're like,
hey,
watch outs or the girl freaks out,
pick up the her dog.
And she figured if she saved coyote
doesn't get a fuck,
she still stalking them down.
And so at that point my mom kind of let
their dog ago and a dog chase the coyote
off and that was that.
But I was like,
man,
those guys are don't.
Yeah,
you don't want to leave leave.
You don't want to do little girls
around.
I know.
It's like why a 10 year old is walking
the doe by ourselves.
That's probably not the best idea.
They um,
there was an instance that happened a
few years back where in 19 year old girl
was murdered,
not murdered,
killed,
partially eaten by coyotes.
Chi Health.
Yeah.
I think the bits and chunks out of her
tore apart and she died in the hospital.
Pretty sure thought.
Yeah.
But there it was unusual circumstances
and the one of the unusual circumstances
that the coyotes in this area are very
limited in terms of what game is
available.
So much so that they've been known to go
after Mousse that these little coyotes
actually go after Moose and have
successfully taken moose out.
Jesus.
Yeah.
So these are gangster coyote.
Next video,
look at that.
They don't look that big.
Yeah they're really big ones.
Like 50 pounds.
Yeah.
I watched a video the other day of a,
a mother Moose trying to uh,
stop these wolves from eating her cow
and her calf.
I've seen that same style.
Terrific.
Yeah.
She's running around and stomping these
wolves and they're circling her and then
they just grabbed the calf and drag it
away and she's fighting off the other
wolves and stomping him.
She stomped the shit out of a few of
them.
Yeah.
She fucked a few of them up.
[inaudible] factual info.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I saw that one.
That one's sucks cause there is Justin
Brown,
that gentleman,
very nice guy.
We got to give us a lot of interesting
insight as to like what happens in um,
you know like with biologists,
how they,
how they track these animals and what,
what some of the problems are.
But we,
we were,
were in such a unique place in southern
California because there's such a
massive population of people,
but there's all these predators that are
sort of like entangles.
Oh yeah.
And our system,
you know,
like hawks
everywhere.
Everywhere you look,
there's hawks swooping down snatch and
doves and shit.
And My,
my daughter got a little dog.
I always felt a little dogs,
her nasty rats,
but I started liking these things.
So I'm like,
okay,
I,
I'm,
I'm changing my mind about it.
This is a cool dog,
but he's still like eight pounds or
something.
So I'm like,
Hey,
you can't let him alone in the yard.
Not because there's probably not coyotes
in the yard,
but they're definitely hawks around.
There's definitely ours look like a big
rabbit [inaudible] in three seconds.
You cannot leave him in the yard like
that because yeah,
I mean that's how it is.
That's when you have trade outdoors
around,
you need to keep your eyes open.
Yeah,
there's no getting around it.
There's no getting around it.
You know,
and when we look at how horrific the
wild world is,
it's not a surprise that people who are
just like recently civilized over the
last,
you know,
like really realistically 10,000 years.
Everybody's like,
there's these really dark thing in
people's minds where it's an opera on
the table.
Most people are never going to pull the
trigger and go down there.
But that's part of,
we are as a,
as human beings.
And I think that's why I enjoy doing
these [inaudible] me lie because he's a
story that's not trying to bash any side
is not like,
oh look at those bad Americans doing
these massacres.
He's more,
they were horrible people there.
There were also great people belonging
to the same side.
So he to me is not about one particular
group of people that one nation or they
want ethnic group or anything being the
bad guys.
He's on an individual level.
What is the mix?
One guy go down this horror in desirable
directions and other people instead
choosing,
you know,
cause that's what you've always done.
You're always choosing not to be that
person.
You know?
That's what fascinates me.
You know,
it's just um,
there's a great book by Sebastian
younger called tribe.
Have you read it?
You read that one,
wasn't it interesting when they talked
to,
but when he talked about all of the
people that were kidnapped by native
Americans that chose to live with them.
Yep.
And then when they were taken back by
the Americans,
by the settlers,
you know,
they were like,
fuck this,
I'm going back.
I'm going back to the native Americans.
And they went and lived with them again,
but no one went the other way.
No.
Which is really crazy.
Something not flat.
They're in about the euro American
culture of the time.
Yeah.
There's a great Benjamin Franklin call
of time.
I'm going to butcher it cause I don't
even remember the beginning.
Something about no European West tasted
savage life and then basically go on.
Can be or to come back to living our
settlements or something like that.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
yeah,
that's see something about fun.
Yeah.
The way they're living their camping,
right?
There's a hunting and fishing every day
and you go back and these assholes were
wearing powdered wigs and banging a
wooden mallet on a table for everybody
to pay attention.
Fuck off SPEC.
That's hilarious.
But that's where you hear you.
That's what I beat about called charts,
right.
People spend time with that romanticize
native college courses like Whoa,
they're old,
you know,
hug trees.
And in talking with the four recruiters
of the forest and I'm like,
well yes and no.
There are like what you mentioned,
right?
If you are capture,
especially in the east when like French
and Indian war or stuff like that,
I work going on,
if you are a capture by,
it would in an that raid one of two
things happen.
The good one is that they like you,
then they decide to adopt you and then
you end up replacing one of their dead
family members.
So like if they lost a brother or a
father,
then you become that person for that
purpose thing that they did.
It's very weird.
But,
but the thing is the adoption process
was so thorough that they love you,
like you're the real deal and you end up
feeling like you're part of this family
and you know everything works out.
It's everything is great if they don't
like you that they torture you to that
of our three day period.
So it's like these are the same people,
right?
They can be the sweetest,
most also be women's or really messed
up.
Same Culture,
same individuals.
Do you think that's just because people
have evolved be dealing with tribal
warfare and just we have to have that
switch?
I think he's a,
because the thing that's interesting
about natives is that it wasn't a racial
thing.
They adopted anybody,
right?
Didn't matter what skin color you will
have that they did not have a barrier
too.
But there is a big insider outsider,
you know,
if you are part of our tribe and you may
become part of our tribe,
race doesn't matter.
You can become part of our tribe,
but once you're part of our tribe,
er one of us.
But if you're not part of our tribe,
then you know the same rules do not
apply to you.
You are whether you are an enemy,
you are.
And in that case that's when it gets
ready a bit older.
Yeah.
Even with other native Americans,
that's the thing that people need to
really get an like we especially people
that only have a peripheral
understanding of native American
culture,
like the reason why sewer called sous
cause that's a native American word for
enemy.
Yup.
They call themselves Lakota people.
Exactly.
So all the other Indians were like fuck
these crazy ass.
It takes you to over there the enemy.
Yeah,
totally.
They were just dominating.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's really fascinating when you
consider that these people had these
hunting grounds and they were trying to
protect and one of the things that
they've found is that there are areas or
wildlife thrived and the wildlife
thrived in these like a gray area
because like this one area would be,
you know,
one native American tribe and then there
are a hunting grounds.
Went to a specific specified distance.
Yup.
No,
obviously always in conflict,
but then pass,
that was another native American tribes.
But in the middle,
that's where you'd find all the fucking
animals of course is they're like,
I get it.
Nobody haunts me.
Or they are worried about killing each
other in New Hampshire zone.
So now I thought that's how it is that
they figured that out.
Yeah.
It's like,
um,
have you been to yellowstone?
Yeah,
it's beautiful.
Right?
It's amazing.
One of the things that's really crazy is
if you go around the tourist center,
there's elk everywhere just lounging
around.
They tell you don't get more than 20
yards closer to a,
an a an alc.
Cause they will charge you occasionally
and they like tired of people taking
fucking self.
He's like,
hey man,
I did it.
I was out there.
I and I've seen elk in the wild.
Wild.
Yeah,
but they've figured out that wolves
don't come to the tourist center.
So like I got an idea and then they
realize these people are different than
the people that hunt us.
Somehow or another,
they put it together like like one day
it'll all could go wrong,
right.
Civilization could collapse and you just
go right to yellowstone,
go to that fucking tourist centers.
There's meet everywhere mold on the APP
because you need hundreds of them on the
lawn at the tourist center.
It doesn't make any sense,
but I don't know what it is like what is
the intellectual process that allows a,
an elk to understand that these people
are not going to try to eat me and that
the wolves are not going to be around
these people.
It barely took some really stupid
dialogue to stick around people before
they realize those are to go to us so
that everybody was looking back at like
Hawaii.
They didn't get killed over there.
They feed feeding and peanuts.
Yeah.
But even though we can try to,
yeah.
Wonder what it was,
I don't know if we really know like the
mechanism that allows them all as a
group to go,
yeah,
you can just chill out around these
people.
Just lie down.
Please lie down if you know us.
You're right.
It is fun.
It all the national parks you see the
most study mode thereby.
It's hilarious.
And it's always,
it's a fascinating that,
no,
there's never been like a non warring
successful group of humans because it
only takes,
you know,
you can really be a pacifist around
somebody who isn't because,
uh,
yeah,
you decide to go in.
It's mellow,
peaceful,
happy society and you get your ass
kicked by.
There's a great story about the origins
of not even before the United States,
like buddy teacher called onesie.
Well,
we'll be coming to the United States.
Everybody hears about the Plymouth Rock,
right?
There's the whole of the puritans.
They show up,
all of that.
What usually people don't hear.
Um,
there was wrestled,
played a little with this store in his
book.
There was these other settlement called
marymount that was just down the street
from Plymouth,
but they were completely different.
Their interpretation of Christianity was
pretty much a,
but he Christiano agonies mix with a
couple of Christian ideas.
They had the exact opposite approach of
the puritans.
They were having drank and orgies with
the native tribes.
They were,
yeah,
they were the equivalent of like the
heat piece of the 16 hundreds just
aching back having fun and deputies.
I started getting edgy because when new
people would show up on the coast,
they would take a look at the puritans.
They would take a look at Mary Mount and
be like,
yeah,
I'm going to marry mouth.
Right.
These guys are whipping themselves.
Life socks over there.
And so of course that was bad.
Even
some puritans were like,
see Johannine I'm gone for a couple of
weeks.
And so the,
the hardcore guys decided,
well we can't have that.
So they got their guns showed up and
close down Mary Mountain and that's the
problem.
Like Ed,
the Marymount guys not be so them plays
a heat piece and actually got their act
together and trained with guns and
stuff.
They would have been able to keep their
community going.
We those values all you just,
you need that minimum of self defense.
So there was somebody else squash,
which is exactly what happened.
Was that the,
from the,
the name Loyola Marymount,
does it come from those people?
I dumped it because,
uh,
you know,
I have no idea.
So I'm going to lie,
but,
but you know,
cause you know,
like y'all,
like does it strike me exactly as a
drunken largest with no,
not at all.
That's why I was confused.
Yeah.
I'd never heard of that before,
but it makes sense that there'd be
someone that would deviate.
There's always someone who just looks at
the way everyone else is doing it and
just says,
this is fucking not for me,
man.
Talk to him.
Yeah.
But it always goes bad.
Like there's never been a cult where,
uh,
you know,
they got together,
formed a commune and just really were
cool to each other.
We,
I'm actually fascinated with exactly the
thing you said.
Why,
why can,
what's so damn hard about power?
It's the ones,
what it is.
One person in power,
the one person in a position of power is
almost always um,
abusive and they almost always used that
power to their own ego,
ego gratification and dominance.
They always fuck all the other guy's
wives.
Yeah.
That's the old,
they all father a bunch of children.
They take everyone's money.
You know,
it's,
I'm fascinated by that kind of stuff
because one of the things that you,
you see when you,
um,
if you become famous or if you do
something that gets you a lot of
notoriety is,
I know how I feel around certain famous
people.
Like,
uh,
I really like,
I've talked about like first time I met
Anthony Bordain who I respect a great
deal.
I was like a little school kid.
I was like,
I was just such a Dork.
dude,
I fucking love your show.
And I was like,
that slabs.
It was jenny.
And I love his writing too.
Yeah.
So it was genuinely excited to see him
and meet him.
You know,
it's still to this day when I talked to
him a little dorked out.
So when you know,
you take a person who's not,
and I'm used to being around
celebrities,
I've been around a lot of them,
but when you take someone who's not used
to being around someone who is in this
position of adoration and they don't
know how to handle it and they just,
they just give in to whatever,
you know,
Beta tendencies that have,
and this Alpha just takes over.
There's a natural thing that human
beings do in these small isolated groups
that don't get checked and it almost
always is the,
the man who is in charge of it winds up
abusing everybody.
Yup,
Yup.
Which again,
it goes back to that pirate of human
nature is what,
why do you have to go down that path?
You can have a great life,
you can enjoy,
be nice to people making,
you are in a position leadership.
You use
that to make sure the whole thing runs.
Mostly everybody's taking care of us
that were pisses me off because you
know,
that occurred to me is,
I mean,
I understand it and I don't understand
it because I mean,
I get it.
I've seen it enough times that I know
you are exactly 100% right,
but at the same time,
I really don't get it because you can
still have a great life.
Nobody's denying you all the good things
that you want.
Just be a semi decent human.
It's not that hard.
Come on,
you would think it's not that hard,
but when there's no one checking you,
look,
you're in the Oregon Woods and you've
got this fucking yogurt and everybody
lives together and you just bang
everybody give you all,
you're all their gold.
It's people for whatever reason,
when there's a person that is the king
or a person that is like some,
you know,
cult leader or whatever your Messiah,
whatever you want to call them,
people just want that person to have the
answers.
They,
they gravitate towards that.
And I think that's better.
Sizely one of the thing that bugs me
about,
um,
a lot of people who are willing to put
themselves in that position of like,
I am your big leader.
To me there's a way to be a leader.
That's awesome.
That's great.
Sort of the Taoist approach where people
shouldn't even feel that you are a
leader by yard,
like sub to the moving sings along to
make sure everybody's taken care of.
That's a leader.
But that's not because it's not all
bills.
Most people need the exactly what you
say dates they need their father figure
to laid out below to be very dogmatic
and so tiny in there.
I know he told,
don't worry,
I have hold the answer.
He's is good,
this is bad.
And people love that.
They love that.
In dictators they love dating or
religious cult leaders.
They love 18 inequity.
Seen that type of personality gathers a
whole lot of full lawyers who need the
somebody to look confident and sure of
themselves.
It doesn't matter whether they are or
they aren't.
If they put on a good show,
people with bite.
Yeah.
It seems like a pattern that just sort
of gets established and human beings
from being a child and having your
parents don't touch that.
That's hot.
Come with me.
This is the way to go.
This is what you have to do.
This is how you put your shoes on.
Does it tie your shoe?
How you get to work this?
I do this to say do that and then you
all of a sudden you don't have anybody
telling you what to do anymore and then
all along comes the cult leader.
Yep,
I've got the answers.
Guess what?
They're coming straight from.
God's a fuck your parents.
My parents didn't know shit but that,
but that's what's funny is that the same
people who grow it up would be like your
parents tell you a tie your shoes and
you're like,
fuck you.
Right.
Suddenly somebody come along with the
are 20 or 30 tie your shoe and you're
like,
oh,
you are so wise and have me,
Lisa is the way at the time,
my shoe.
Oh,
great master.
Exactly.
There's just,
I don't know man.
It's just,
it was interesting.
I don't know if you have been following
like where I'm Dan Carlin,
the stuff that he has been saying about
his other show.
Common Sense.
I haven't listened to it lately.
Yeah,
he hasn't been releasing ips on lately.
That's probably why you haven't because
he has kind of shut down with that.
It's not officially done,
but in thing is my approach,
meaning Dan talking,
my approach is to be calm.
What somewhat sub though?
Somewhat like play and not be overly
dogmatic one way or another to think on
my feet to mix mixings together and that
some scene that most people don't want
in the current climate,
most people want the very black and
white type of approach.
Now I disagree with Dan because I think
that steel,
there is an enormous need for what he
provides and I don't think that just
giving up is the solution,
but I do get it because it really
doesn't take much.
You know,
if you start screaming a very dogmatic,
either super leftist or super
conservative approach,
you get out to magically a bunch of
folders.
If you are thinking on your feet and
just going,
hmm,
this thing,
yeah,
you're right,
but let's look at the other side and
constantly,
I mean,
you know what any decent human being
should do.
Just be an intellectually honest and
thinking sinks.
People don't respond to that because
it's not that easy or rather people do.
Some people respond,
but he's a number wise is a way a
minority compared to what you get by
being a black and white kind of guy.
Yeah.
People desire very clear resolutions and
very clear thinking in terms of like a
enemy.
Friends.
Yes,
this is a black and white issue.
There's,
but I think Dan,
that also just felt overwhelmed by the
times.
It's like this just seems like
everything's so fucked up.
I'd rather not even talk about it.
Just sit back and see what is really
happening.
We were on the phone,
I swear I spend like an hour on the
phone way you or whoever back and forth.
I was playing in bye bye.
That was played a remembered a second
movie of Lord of the Rings where there's
for all the old [inaudible]
yeah,
I can't do this anymore.
And they're sab going,
oh,
come on.
You need to,
I think I,
I need to step up my game.
I'm a Shitty Sam because I was trying to
do that for that and it just kind of
motivate him and I miss it.
I really failed.
So I respect where he's coming from.
He said that when he was on the show
recently,
um,
he,
he was talking about that sort of same
thing that he's kind of put that podcast
on hold long as he keeps doing his
podcast.
Hardcore history is just so important I
think.
I think him and you are providing,
you guys are providing uh,
an entertaining and interesting history
lesson that really wasn't available
before.
I mean before he could get a book on
tape and if is really well written book
and it was read by someone with like
good dramatic flare.
It was exciting stuff but nobody really
got into it.
I bet.
I bet the numbers,
if you consider the numbers of people
that have listened to his podcast and
your podcast in comparison to like
before you guys were around,
there's probably a radically improved
number of people that know a lot about
history.
Yeah.
For particular things like the Mongols.
I never even thought about the Mongols
until I listened to his podcast,
which apparently right now if you're in
the La area in Simi Valley,
at the Ronald Reagan Museum,
the Reagan Museum or a library,
what is it?
There's a giant Genghis Khan exhibit
Railey.
Yeah.
They have the bows and all the stuff
they stole and the textiles and all the
dif different things.
They warn their yurts that they slept in
all kinds of crazy shit.
Awesome.
Want to go?
Yeah.
I mean that stuff's over a thousand
years old,
right?
Or close to it.
There was 1200 scouts.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yes.
So close to a thousand years old.
Yeah,
but oh,
there it is right there.
Yeah.
Check it out.
They had bows that required 160 pounds
to pull back.
I know.
What the hell were these guys?
So we'll pull this 60 pound boy.
It's insane.
And they must have been animals.
There must've been so fucking strong.
Yeah,
you'll put 60 pounds and you're like,
holy hell,
this is heavy.
Hundred and 60 is insane.
Well,
I have a,
um,
up compound bow and the compound bow.
I don't have a regular,
like a recurve,
like these guys should.
I believe they invented the recurve too.
They didn't invent it.
They were around in the era when the
recurve was invented,
which just by the design of the bow,
it pulls,
it's,
it gives you more power,
more energy gets released through the
Arrow.
But w with a compound bow,
there's a big led off.
So it's only difficult.
So if you had a 60 pound bow,
it's only deaf,
it's only 60 pounds for like the first
six inches of shell pulling it back.
Then as you completely pull back,
there's like an 85% led off.
So it's much easier to hold.
Right though.
They were pulling 160 the whole title
the way,
and it was harder.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
And they could aim a perfectly on
horseback while the rally they knew full
gallop is like who,
I mean they apparently used to time the
Arrow release while the horse was in the
air.
Yeah.
Cause then you don't have the unevenness
of faith.
You,
it doesn't guys weren't sakes.
It just that that ct has that Dan did on
the Mongols is one of the greatest of
all time.
I urged me,
it's I think it causes a dollar an
episode.
Just go through Itunes,
get it for a dollar or I don't know what
other,
um,
whatever it could be.
Do you have,
if you're cheap android,
but it's a dollar an episode and it's
worth fucking hundreds of dollars.
It's amazing.
I've listened to it.
No bullshit.
At least six times.
Hit Up Heidi to stop bringing up Dan
because by now people are accusing me of
like,
you know,
you like Dan probably a little more than
a little sexual man.
Sure.
The [inaudible] beautiful guy.
He's also nothing wrong with it.
I love Dan is one of my favorite humans.
Well listen to your podcast is fucking
awesome to men and I really particularly
enjoyed your first one because you
talked about that one store that you
brought up on him freaked me the fuck
out.
Right when the end of [inaudible] they
uh,
they capture all the remnants of
Spartacus army and [inaudible] fight
every scene called one of them on the
way between the Naples and Capitola,
but next to Naples,
Naples,
and Rome and every,
whatever,
30,
40 yards,
and there's a new guy crucified and 30
yards down.
And neither one was kind of like lamp
posts all the way between these two
cities.
And how many miles is that?
That's like 120,
something like that.
Hundred and 20 miles of crucified
people.
Yeah.
Where you have at devry,
30 to 40 yards.
There's a new one and then another one
and then another one.
And it's,
yeah,
that's a,
any kind of story since the last time
you were on the podcast,
I went to Rome.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
I saw that traveling the,
yeah.
Yeah,
dude,
it's,
that's one of those things where you
just have to like,
no one talked to me for a second.
Let me try to process this.
You know,
like we had a great guide,
uh,
who is a professor who was a really,
it was really cool.
He guides people in the meantime and he
was just so excited to talk to me
because I was so into it.
Of course,
you know,
because most of the time,
people are just like barely curious
about what he has to say.
But you know,
we,
we talked about the significance of the
pineal gland and the pine cone and the
in the Vatican and he know he takes you
on a tour of all the different
artifacts.
That's,
that's a trip that I feel like,
but just going there,
especially the Vatican going near the
coliseum was big too.
But going to the Vatican and just seeing
all that artwork and getting an
understanding of what those people were
really up to four hundreds and hundreds
of years,
just conquering the world for hundreds
and hundreds of years and all this
artwork.
Yeah.
Seeing it live in person.
Just sort of reset my perspective.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
It's a,
yeah.
Romy is a place that he hadn't never
once in your lifetime you've got to do
it.
You know,
he's just a,
I don't know if you have been,
there's a place,
a sentence Santangelo's which is kind of
close to the Vatican and,
but if you go to the top of this castle,
you're basically,
you got to panoramic view will fold off
at all from there.
It's so spectacular.
It's wild river.
You'll see all the buildings you'll see
every single,
then you kind of like mech down and
you're justin do we our walks and,
and uh,
why was I saying here?
Oh,
one thing that I swear over that I was
blown away by,
you know,
desire,
it tastes kind of a joe was the painter.
Never that guy.
I love that guy because basically what
happens with this dude is he was around
in the,
what was the end of the 59 yeah.
I ended up the 59 [inaudible] 69 and
kind of agile was straight up against
there.
Like he was probably the best artist of
the arl to me.
He's probably the best artist of all
time.
He's like,
you look at his paintings and it's just
insane what he could do with paint.
But then he had this life on the street,
asic as electoral gains there.
He would just get,
he at one point killed the guy in a duel
was wanted for barder.
Every time he would get close to power
and the will be up.
That's kind of agile for you.
Okay.
Right.
They're raising that painting is,
and what year was this made around?
God,
look how good it is.
I know.
That is insane.
I mean that's,
that is so close to photographic and you
think that this is in the 16 hundreds
and these people,
they couldn't even stand still for him.
I mean,
how do you think he did that?
Did he have a guy pretend that he's
getting choked?
Did do this all from his mind?
No,
I think he was models.
There was actually one of the scandals
is that he thinks in his models.
Well of course,
but that was not this guy.
I'll do that.
Right.
That was part of the deal though,
that scandal power was the fact that,
you know,
the Church was commissioner in a lot of
his work,
but he's clearly was not the most pious
guy in their sense.
He's view of Christianity was a,
hey these guys where Jesus and his
followers who were poor man from the
street,
they were not the power Denali in purple
the roads.
So he used the small dose more than
Lance for the Virgin Mary.
He was the hoop so that he was leaping.
Wait,
a church is like,
you're kind of dog.
He was a hooker for the Virgin Mary.
That's just not okay.
He would be like,
yeah,
don't worry.
Okay.
Next time and a gate.
He does.
They take eight CV,
get some of his paintings of the Virgin
Mary's fine.
Some of them.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
It's hilarious.
There's one,
uh,
let me see if I remembered thought.
There's one where there's a naked baby
Jesus,
which Mary squashing and snake a cif
that pops up that what is great because
uh,
you know,
they,
that was his big shot at making a big
and a church was trying,
okay,
keep it together.
Be a good boy because they are the best
painter there is,
but you are fucking crazy.
So please just tone it down.
And he turns seem these painting where
the Virgin Mary as a just big cleavage
showing you that I had to dress,
she'd maybe Jesus,
he's buck naked.
Squashing the snake.
Supposed to symbolize that they have all
that staff and they were like,
yeah,
that's not what we bet the one that's
the Virgin Mary.
She looks like a freak.
I know.
Well she was he so love or hooker.
So yes,
that was part of the problem.
There are baby Jesus squash.
The snake was dick show and fix that.
That was the other thing that,
um,
this guy was explaining to me was a
penis sizes of the Roman statues.
They were all small because big penises
were supposed to mean stupid people and
like aggressive animals that were just,
you know,
not a part of the civilized,
amazing culture that Rome represented.
So there was pride in the micro penis?
Yeah,
well it wasn't micro but it was
definitely not,
that's not optimal.
Yeah,
it was like,
cause I was asking,
I was like,
what do you think that is?
We were trying to figure it out when we
were talking about it before the
professor gave me an answer and I was
like,
maybe they just like had little riddicks
back then.
Like maybe it was just,
you know,
that was just how it went.
And he's like,
no,
it just,
I think they probably associated with
big dicks with rape,
with like the,
the barbarians and the Moore's and all
these people coming in and chopping
people up and fucking the shit out of
everybody and like,
no,
we don't want that.
They don't want that little tiny dicks
like the sophisticated dicks Dick's and
people who write poetry,
vandalism.
No,
they still a big dicks though.
They were there were clearly made by the
artist.
One thing they did do though in certain
errors they covered the dicks with
leaves and it wasn't initially what they
would do and they went back on a lot
them and repurpose
them and put new leaves over dicks.
I think you know right now that are
going to be about seven pank beds.
Boring the name from you,
like sophisticated the will be the name
of new punk band coming out tomorrow.
Good bands.
Sophisticated dicks.
I like that name.
That's a good one.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a weird thing that people have done
throughout history.
It's like sort of um,
trying to uh,
trying to control artistic expression
and trying to have it represent the time
and so you don't necessarily get a full
version of what was going on then,
but you do get a version of the
suppression which gives you insight into
the full version of the times.
Definitely.
You know,
that they were covering,
covering Dick's with leaves and stuff,
so,
so strange.
And sometime they would have the pain 30
giving the Dat third version of the
painting for public consumption.
But then the same guy will commission.
He was like,
okay,
give me a while for my tribe.
I call latch on.
And so that's where they would have all
the way more explicit stuff.
Yeah.
They,
I mean,
they didn't have pornography back then,
so they must been beaten off the
paintings and stuff.
Had to be,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean it had to be thought of as being
arousal inducing.
So much so that,
what was it during the Victorian era
where they put legs of tables,
they would put dresses on them.
Yeah.
They would rapid the legs of the tables
because you know,
they are legs each day.
Our Bayer,
they may give you ID.
Yes.
Which I don't know about you man.
But you know,
look at the leg of that.
That really doesn't do wait for me.
So the something to it where people got
so horny,
the table leg,
this skin,
uh,
but that's what your door,
you'll really have problems,
right.
When you look at the leg of a table and
you got all excited,
he's like,
man,
yeah,
that's not good.
No,
you'll be whatever.
Revies each your life choice.
That's up until that point.
It's fascinating to see.
People must've agreed to that too.
What's up Jamie?
I just looked it up.
It says it,
that it originates from a satire that
was written and people,
I guess took it as truth.
Oh,
so it's not real.
Yeah,
I supposedly not,
but they definitely did cover the legs.
They did.
But the reason why this exaggerated,
since he was poking fun at Americans
that did something like that,
I'll come up to this point of the meat.
The meat is too cool.
That's prosperous farmhouse parlor in 19
hundreds and that isn't covered,
but this is 19 hundreds,
right?
This is,
um,
the Victorian era is when they did this.
Oh wait.
Okay.
1839 and Englishman wrote a satire of
American tour.
He wrote the American propensity to use
the word limb and place of leg though he
says the English two a two.
Then he says that he visited a boarding
school,
young ladies,
New York Strip,
we,
sorry,
square piano forte with four limbs.
Their mistress of the establishment had
dressed all these four limbs in modest
trousers with frills at the bottom of
them.
He's exaggerating or not subjects,
uh,
is exaggerating or not subject to
speculation.
He certainly poking fun or whether
whether Mur Mur Mur yet is exaggerating
or not is subject to speculation.
He is certainly poking fun and
Americans.
But I can attest that having page who
dozens of books showing old black and
white piano photos of Victorian tier is
a saw not one example of a table piano
or any other piece of furniture with
skirts around the individual legs.
That's interesting.
Boom.
I liked the legends so much matter.
Hadn't you always heard that from
professors?
I remember hearing that from a history
professor.
I'm old off the,
you know,
between boring he story and a fun legend
or west side.
Yeah.
I would like to think that people were
way more stupid than they were.
It makes me feel good about this error.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You'd be this,
um,
I mean you look at the dresses that
people had to wear that when all the way
down to the ground.
I mean,
this is not really much different than
what we see in the Middle East.
It's very simple.
I mean,
what we see in the Middle East,
they have to cover their face.
They had job and the whole deal and the
headscarves,
and that's a little,
little more extreme,
but not much.
Yeah.
I mean they,
they wore shit that went all the way to
the ground.
If you showed any ankle,
you would lose their mind and said,
hey,
call,
why am I crazy?
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
repetition does it.
Yeah.
I wonder if they were more
hypersexualized than we are.
I bet not.
I bet because of porn we're probably
more hypersexualized.
Right?
There's,
I think different arguments there
because some people say the more
[inaudible] stuff,
the more than you're going to obsess
with it.
So that's all you think about all day.
[inaudible]
he's less likely to obsess.
Then again,
there are lots of people are so addicted
to Internet porn that,
I don't know if that the idea works,
but you know,
that's the,
well,
Internet porn is the problem that
Annette porn is,
the availability is this.
You don't even have to go some way.
At least back in the day when you had
vhs tapes or dvds or something like
that,
you had to go to a store,
you had to buy him.
He had to put them into the TV at a sit
back.
Yeah.
Get the remote control.
There's a process.
There was work involved.
The miners have minor work,
right?
Yes.
Now it's just far too easy as far.
I mean,
how many people that work that have jobs
go into the bathroom,
locked the door and beat off.
That's a lot of people listening right
now.
Where do we did exactly that and that
right now you're beaten off right now.
Stop it.
Go back to work.
Jesus.
He's watching.
That's what I hear.
Yeah.
Um,
it's just,
it's interesting,
I guess if you have to think about it.
Like they were trying to control those
people and trying to control their urges
because it was beneficial to society.
It was beneficial to society that,
that these people needed to do their
fair share and get to work and they
couldn't just be staring at legs all
day.
And,
and,
you know,
engaging in an impure thoughts and,
but you know,
that's the,
that's the problem.
We tiny kind of probation.
It's completely misunderstanding of the
human mind works is you do not say no to
seeing says you are not going to do
this.
Yup.
Guaranteeing that are to obsessed with
this.
Right.
It doesn't work.
There's um,
how's that sad story that I heard once
that I thought he was hilarious.
I can't remember where I read it,
but like guy go to a zen masters saying,
hey,
you know,
you'll be called like peace and happy.
I want to be just like you.
What do I need to do?
Zen Master says,
okay,
just for the next 24 hours,
don't think about monkeys,
guys like molten keys never floated
about monkeys.
Him.
I was that gonna make me a light zen
masters.
Dot.
Shut up.
Go Away.
Come back in 24 hours.
Don't think about monkeys.
Kind of like,
okay,
well be coming in a light and it's going
to be a piece of cake because all I have
to do is not think about monkeys.
And of course the next 24 hours become
the most monkey field hours of his life.
Cause that's the only kind of thing come
out right for it.
Big The bore.
You make sense in get taboo,
the board,
you'd guarantee that people are going to
obsess with it.
Yeah,
it's a like he didn't think like
drinking at 21 in us.
Right.
It was like growing up.
I don't even know if there was an age in
Italy where you're supposed to not drink
but is not that glamorous,
you know,
is what your grandparents have for lunch
and you know you are maybe six year old
and you want to try a little wine and
they give you a tiny bit saying if you
have a little more you got a headache.
So just got it.
And then one day you do get a little
more,
you got a headache and you go,
oh shit,
you're right.
Okay.
And you kind of learn how to drink
rather than being like wait God away.
Cool.
Now we got all this booze and people
drink.
Throw up all over themselves is like,
that hasn't got a hose.
Why are you doing?
Yeah,
I think there's definitely a healthier
attitudes than Americans' attitudes
about alcohol,
but also like wine is a good way to
start.
Like he started off a kid with whiskey.
That's not the way to start as too
potent amount of my first times I ever
got drunk was on Jack Daniels until
years for me to smell Jack Daniel's and
not want to throw up.
I'm sure he gets those triggers in your
head.
We smell it like Jaeger.
My,
I used to smell yeager mine.
It's like,
and just be like,
Yep.
It's just think about just getting
violently ill where your body's trying
to purge it from your system so you
don't die yet.
It's to,
to hide it from kids and tell them it's
that,
that it's taboo,
but then you drank it and then they're
like,
I can't wait until these fucking people
can't tell me what to do anymore to help
get myself a nice cold glass of whiskey.
Yeah,
I mean it's kind of like that goes over
to this to education in general.
You know when,
if a parent has to come to the place
where you say these are the rules,
you live under my roof,
you need to pay them.
That's like raising the white flag and
that meeting,
I've lost all that idea.
I lost control.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing
cause it's like of course all the are
going to do is wait for you to turn
around and do exactly the senior
prohibiting cause they are coming across
as a dictator.
You're coming across as an asshole.
If instead you can teach somebody like,
look man,
you can whatever you want the gold
leader is,
we want to make sure we both want to
make sure that you're happy and you're
safe,
simple enough.
So let's figure out a strategy to make
sure you can be happy and safe and we
are on,
I'm on board,
whatever.
That's a lot easier for people to
respond to be like,
okay so you're not just a kill joy who
was trying to squash my life.
You are somebody who was concerned about
me not ending up dead.
Fair enough.
We couldn't work with that.
Yeah.
But parents have to work.
And then don't have any time.
Exactly.
I don't have to tell you you're a
parent.
Right.
You know,
like,
just fucking listen to me.
Just shut up.
I'm tonight busy writing my book over
here.
Fucking get my lectures ready.
And kids like,
hey,
what about whiskey?
Don't fucking touch that shit.
Get out of that.
Get out of that liquor cabinet.
Right.
Yeah.
I remember when I was a kid,
I couldn't wait to drink.
It has the course.
This is going to be fun.
Of course.
Gotta be this taboo.
Yup.
It's forbidden.
Yep.
So,
but that's the problem that we'd
forbidden stuff.
It never works well.
It's also a Italian food and wine seem
to go hand in hand and,
and it's,
I think,
I mean,
did they used to be what they drank
because they were concerned with getting
sick.
Right.
And one of the best ways to not get sick
was to drink wine.
Yeah.
Because,
well,
yeah,
the alcohol content would keep the water
from,
I mean like if you just drink water all
the time,
especially if it's sitting still,
you could get some bad fucking water.
Right?
You can get bad water from a lake.
I mean,
how many,
they didn't know Jack Shit about
parasites back then.
How many people got some terrible
diseases from drinking puddle water and
shit?
You know,
I'm sure a lot.
Oh yeah.
He just find some water like,
oh,
we're thirsty.
Time to drink.
Or even at creek you drink in a creek
and you think like,
oh,
this is a beautiful stream.
This is a clear water.
Yeah.
But a beaver took a shit just a hundred
yards of so that you don't know about
it.
You get what's called beaver fever.
That's what you're for real.
That's what they called Giardia.
They call it beaver fever.
Yeah.
That can be good.
Now it's terrible.
So they used to drink wine to prevent
what they would call traveler's disease
because people would take these,
those,
what are those things called?
The leather things that they would carry
wine and I want to say flask but it's
not a flask.
One of those,
those leather satchels,
they know what they're about.
[inaudible] I thought they use
philosopher dots but I'm not sure.
It might be,
there's a term it's like a leather bag
and it had like a on the end like a cork
and they just drink from that and that's
how they would hydrate.
Yup.
People must have been just hammered all
day when you read the statistics of how
much people used to drink.
It's amazing that anything got article
done cause it's just people where that
ain't good morning through night and
they must have been horrific to each
other.
Then just just to imagine like a whole
civilization that is a drunken bar at
1:00 AM angry drunk you.
Yeah.
It's funny cause I never,
I mean I've seen it enough that I get
it.
People get edgy and weird where when day
drink too much,
but I never got it because to me it's
like if I'm drunk he like that's when
I'm happy.
I want to tag people.
Why would I be in a bad mood is awesome.
This for,
you're a nice guy.
That's what it is.
That comes out the,
yeah.
If you're a fucking asshole,
you,
she'll drop.
I see.
Especially if you just barely keep in
that ass hole under the surface,
just barely just wondering science,
stab her,
but in club them and steal their women.
And then you get a couple of drinks in
you and this,
this is alcohol.
Alcohol is a great social lubricant.
It's great for releasing inhibitions and
letting people communicate with each
other more freely and have fun.
But it's also,
it removes doubt and that's not good.
I think town is critical.
Like doubt is one of the pieces of the
great puzzle,
right?
The,
the great puzzle has many ingredients
and one of those ingredients is doubt
and doubt is important.
You should look at anything you're about
to contemplate and go think about this.
Let me think what could go wrong when
you get a couple of drinks.
Fuck it.
Let's do it.
Let's go.
And then next thing you know,
you know you're on an Internet meme.
Hold my beer.
Yeah,
exactly.
We talked about that yesterday,
like some of the most more ridiculous
ones,
but there's so many of those out there
and almost all of them I have to do with
alcohol.
Yeah,
no,
you are totally right.
And I think what you saying about dove,
there's a great Alan Watts,
the guy who polarizes an and that weighs
in Mendota,
that stuff.
He had these good eighth line,
he called it the wisdom of insecurity.
These idl that I had to re careful.
There's a lease,
don't dairy,
not being sure he'd dogmatic and which
doesn't mean the problem is then people
take that concept to fire and that
donating to having no bowls and not
being able to pick a standard.
That's not a solution either.
That's the other side of the problem.
But there's a sweet spot in between
where you can take stances,
but they are careful statuses.
They are sent stances that are very
willing to be change at the drop of a
dime if you show the good evidence to to
change them.
You know?
He's,
that to me is what the intellectual
honesty looks like,
you know?
Yeah,
I agree.
I think it's good to be aware of all the
possibilities.
I used to tell people that when I was a
teaching taekwondo,
like people that would compete if there
were really,
really nervous,
I'd be like the really smart people are
really nervous because you're aware of
all the possibilities of everything that
could go wrong.
The people that aren't worried about it
at all,
they're usually dumb.
There's that,
but also to me there are some people,
like I look at some of the people were
able to keep it together in this like
kind of like Chuck [inaudible],
right?
Take a nap right before a fight kind of
thing.
I can't tell by looking at those guys
and just be like,
you'd have something.
I don't know what you know there's
something there that you are doing.
Confidence for sure.
I mean chuck had been knocking people
unconscious for many,
many years and he knew exactly what to
do and I think knew he was good at it.
There's that for sure.
And I think there's the other side is
knowing that,
okay,
if I have decided to do it,
fear is not going to help me now you
know that me to make decisions so
earlier,
but right now he's not going to help me.
So let's figure out,
man.
It was hilarious.
There's um,
my girlfriend fights mma professionally
and she notice that yeah,
she's wise man.
Been paying attention to uh,
your escapades online.
She's,
she's crazy.
She's crazy.
She said she lita Lee at that chuck
Liddell mode where she,
she took a nap right before a fight and
you know,
like 45 minutes before you have to wake
her up going like,
hey roddy.
And she's all like,
okay,
ready to roll.
And I'm like,
I would not sleep for a week prior.
How do you manage to keep it together?
Kids do.
I used to do that.
I used to sleep before fights.
It's good.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
But you,
you just can get yourself into a more
calm state.
It's so much better than I'm frantically
running around and freaking out.
Threading plus is a,
it's a,
it freaks out your opponents.
I would sleep like right in the
bleachers.
I just go to sleep right there and
everybody else would be nervous and
shit.
And you're sleeping.
Exactly.
Do you look at them and then I'm
supposed to fight that guy.
The guy was leaping right before the
fight.
Hell No.
Like the first to match studied.
I was nuts because you know,
you're in the locker room and there's
the guy sitting next to you goes out for
his match.
Come right back.
[inaudible]
you get ready,
you're going next.
And I'm dying,
right?
I'm just seeking out to hell.
And she's all like la La la.
Where'd you meet her gym?
Uh,
no.
She literally live across the street
from me.
That's crazy.
And it was funny because I used to say
it,
this is where the universe as a sense of
humor,
because I used to say all the time,
like I'm kind of,
I can get along with anybody but I don't
necessarily click with a lot of people.
So my thing was like,
yeah,
where do I find somebody?
I click with Laura across the street and
I said,
they're like pen pals and dies right at
what they have.
Like look at that.
That's hilarious.
I know he was looking at the universe
going like,
okay,
that's funny,
ha ha,
but the this definitely like little
things that almost like slap you in the
face with,
yeah,
there's a whole system going on.
Stupid.
It just pay attention.
Like I know you make fun of Oprah,
but the secret might be real mother
fucker.
Oprah has got $3 billion.
See it his way to do it all.
It seems completely preposterous,
but yeah.
Intellectually I always want to say Nah.
You know,
then things don't happen for a fucking
reason.
You decide they happen for a reason
afterwards.
Yeah,
because it helps fit your sense of
order.
It's the funny thing is I completely
agree with that and I also completely
agree with the fact that sometimes sinks
clicking away.
Then you're like,
okay,
you're a fucking wait to meet these is
just to think about people all the time.
Out of nowhere.
I'll get an email from him like out of
nowhere,
like I haven't talked to this guy in 10
fucking years and then all of sudden I
get an email or you know,
you run into them somewhere,
like what?
How is it possible I'm running into at
the airport?
Like this doesn't even make sense.
I know you reconnect.
It's very strange.
Yeah,
there those are the times when he really
humbles you and makes you think,
okay,
the university such a weird place and
what I understand he's like,
but release 0.01% of what's out there.
Yeah.
We're connected in some other weird,
bizarre way that we haven't figured out
yet and maybe we'll never will.
Maybe we'll become symbiotics.
Maybe it will become like completely
ingrained technologically before we
figure out the biological connections
that we share because I think there's,
I think there's like the obvious senses
that we all have,
but I think there's some other stuff
going on.
When you think about someone and then
boom,
they're,
they're calling you on the phone like
that.
Dad,
just to me is too coincidental
sometimes.
Sometimes it's random.
Sure.
Like say if it's someone that you talk
to all the time and then they call you,
that's just coincidental.
But there's some times man,
where you just,
you're talking about someone and also in
the fucking phone rings and I go look at
this.
This is crazy.
Yep.
You haven't talked to them at four years
exact calling you right there.
Exactly.
There's something to that.
Yup.
And they,
and you asked them like,
why did you call me?
Just stop right now.
I'm not,
I'm not saying like,
why are you calling me?
I'm saying like what was going on?
Like what caused you to call me?
I don't know.
Just had a weird feeling rod.
Oh fuck man.
That's crazy though.
If it's always the things.
Yeah,
that's,
yeah.
Then you could also tell when people are
creepy too,
right?
You can tell when someone's a creep.
Just like there's something,
the vibe that you'll pick up weird vibe.
Like what is that like?
What's that?
I really do think that there's something
that,
you know,
verbal communication,
when he's a vet,
he's mold way in which we communicate.
There's so much more clear.
It's cause you know,
there are times when you walk into a
room and you will that I didn't know who
you are going to like and what you're
doing.
You and the ones that you don't,
then you need to spend the next whatever
long it takes you to find the reason why
you don't click that you will.
I didn't know it.
There's that something there is going on
and the smell and I thought,
I don't think most people could ask
their perception.
So they are like,
no,
no.
I need to find out the rationale,
the reason why would I have these
preconceptions I need.
To me,
it's like if you feel it just partly
good,
the reason for it,
you know,
if you have a strong feeling about it,
how would that I state rather than not
fuck yeah,
yeah.
Trusted rather than not as a good way
and you know,
don't trust it.
Like that's definitely a witch.
Yeah.
No,
not that.
Do not burn.
Knew it.
Do not burn your people at the stake.
That's a bad idea.
You know,
that was a weird time too.
Right.
It's just amazing to me that,
um,
the United States is such a recent sort
of experiment in self government and
that no one has done anything like that
since then.
That's what's kind of really amazing to
me when to stop and think about all the
wacky shit that's taking place in
America over the last 300 plus years and
then no one else has done that.
No one else has said,
look,
we found the spot in Australia and the
Australian government is allowed us to
carve off a big chunk and that's,
let's call it,
you know,
whatever.
Then Daniella land,
I'm all for it.
That I swear I'll be a good leader.
I,
well,
it's going well.
Your wives maybe.
It seems like what it's also amazing is
that the United States has managed to
become the number one superpower in the
world as a a group of all crazy
immigrants.
That all moved into one spot.
Yup.
Yeah.
Know the story of the United States is
fascinating because he had you don't,
and probably is never going to happen
again because you know,
that was the proud owner of a word I did
not know about.
Oh,
there's this other column,
you know,
you'll find out.
It's a new,
it's exciting.
It's 76 now.
You'll know what's out there and then,
unless you go for space exploration,
nothing like these will happen in the
history of planet earth.
It just,
the only way it can happen is a reset.
A civilization reset.
Like there'd have to be like a bunch of
people die.
Like most people die.
I Paul called libs.
Most people lose the knowledge of what
was going on before then.
Yeah,
sure.
He'll can have a post Grad Manco kind of
story.
Yeah.
Post Graham Hancock,
that's entirely possible.
Yeah,
Although I did read something very
recently that they think,
um,
what was the,
a supervolcano that killed most people
on the planet 70,000 years ago.
They found one pocket of humans that
actually survived and thrived in Africa.
But they think that the entire
population of a human beings at that
point in time,
70,000 years ago,
the entire population in the world was
only around a hundred thousand people.
It's,
yeah.
And then it dropped down to 10,000 wow.
10,000 people because of the Super
Volcano.
So the super volcano blew.
It wiped out most life.
It wiped out most people.
It plunged the earth into some sort of a
nuclear winter.
I forgot where it was.
I want to say it was Bali or Indonesia
Toba.
Where was that?
Indonesia.
Indonesia Sumatra killed.
Literally 90% of the people and 10,000
were left.
So 70,000 years ago we were down at
10,000 humans,
which makes all the sinks about racism.
So sealy,
cause that's a,
that's a good show for Kevin Hart that
even that's a light crowd for Kevin
Hart's.
Exactly how she got 10,000 people.
Yeah.
It's like a fucking blink one 82
concert.
10,000 people,
man,
that's nothing that you stop and think
about that.
It's insane.
I've done 10,000 people in the night
before in uh,
Denver.
I did two shows.
There are 5,000 each.
That's 10,000 people.
That's the fucking entire population of
earth and that now became 7 billion.
70,000 years later.
It's nuts.
We're so weird where it's such a weird
animal.
Like if you could study us without being
us,
like if somehow I know that you could
remove all of your cultural conceptions
and all the,
all the things that you've just sort of
accepted and you establish as fact as a
human and just look at it completely
objective,
you'd be like,
what are nutty animal?
This thing is what the fuck are we
doing?
Yeah.
That's why
it never gets old to study the human
psyche.
Like what makes people choose this?
Because that's the beauty of human
beings.
We have choices that,
you know,
Eh,
at Wolf is a wolf.
There are only so many things you can
choose as a wall for your,
you know?
Yeah.
You could have a world that adopts one
strategy,
one another,
but the range of choices is pretty
limited.
As humans,
we have this insane range of choices and
he's fascinated to see what is the,
make some people going one direction in
a completely different one and it's fun.
It is fun.
It,
and what's fascinating to me about human
beings of today is I've never seen a
time where people were more interesting,
more interested rather in other people
doing what they want them to do,
like other people thinking the way they
want them to think,
other people behaving the way they want
the people want.
It seems to me are more concerned with
controlling people's expression and
thinking today than ever before and even
more so on the left.
It seems like I'm seeing this
interesting trend today where people
like,
it's almost like we don't like where
things are headed.
We don't like what's happening.
We don't like who the president is.
So people are are being real adamant
about enforcing certain types of
behavior and that in turn,
just like we're talking about
suppressing people from drinking
alcohol,
then in turn makes people rebel.
Of course that's like there's more
people that are leaning right today than
ever before and I attribute it entirely
to the people on the left piano to thing
that's funny about it is that most human
beings,
even if you've just,
we'll cut the United States,
right?
Most people are not the extreme right or
extreme left.
No Fair whelming majority or not,
right.
I think a lot of the staff is also a
little bit media created in the sense
that he's like,
let's find a moss batshit crazy person
on that side to put the spotlight on
them,
which make everybody go like,
what the fuck?
Why are those crazy people?
And that's how,
it's kind of like if you were to peek,
you know,
the Westboro Baptist Church and make it
be a representative of Christianity.
It's like it's not,
you're nobody.
If you keeps putting the spotlight
there,
you'll create this perception with
Korea,
tobacco collage and it becomes this
thing where like that sounded funny
thing that I was in the ltcm because I
really don't like political correctness.
I really don't like academia.
I really don't.
You know,
there are 10,000 of these things where
I'm like,
yeah,
that's,
I'm completely on board with not liking
some of these things.
But then there's another side where,
you know,
I have been teaching a university since
2001 I don't think I've seen once a case
of the kind of political correctness
that I see in articles in media now,
lance,
you know,
like I was doing the math.
I had probably maybe 11,000 students in
my classes over the course of these
years and I don't,
I haven't heard one person ever the fan
hardcore communism or make an argument.
Even among my colleagues,
which I have
issues for other reason.
That's never been one of the things.
So I'm like,
I keep hearing about it.
I read it on papers by why is that when
I spend,
you know,
that's how I make my living.
I'm on college campuses all the time.
I hardly ever see it.
And so I'm thinking,
I'm not saying that he's not through.
Of course.
I mean,
of course the stories are true.
There's no argument.
But what I'm wondering is how much do
they get blown out of proportion because
you get clicks because it makes for an
interesting narrative which dance.
Some people also leave off kind of
narrative and I'm like,
how much is it something where you're
putting the spotlight on a rare
exception and make it the norm versus
how much?
It's a real thing because you know,
you would expect,
I mean I teach in south around
California and some of the ones who
leave them,
you know,
Santa Monica is one of the most liberal
places around.
If d seeing was as dominant as
advertised,
I should be running into it all the
time.
Right.
And I don't like that stuff.
So I would be sensitive,
you know,
I would be paying attention and yet I
don't see it.
So I'm like,
hmm,
what's going on here?
That's interesting.
Well,
I think the instances are more frequent
than ever before.
But I also think if you put it into
perspective and think about how many
universities there are across the
country,
I mean there are hundreds and hundreds
of universities and if you have one
incident that breaks out one month in
one place exactly.
And it was about one conservative
speaker that's going to give a lecture
and everybody freaks out and goes crazy
and all the people with green hair
fucking bang on the windows.
It's a,
it becomes something that people were
worried about spreading.
And so I think that's one of the,
one of the reasons,
cause like I'm sure you're familiar with
the story from Evergreen University,
Evergreen state.
Yup.
That was a fascinating story.
And for people who are interested in it,
Google,
uh,
Bret Weinstein and um,
evergreen state college and you could
listen to him on my podcast.
I had him on right after it all went
down.
What had happened was there's a thing
called the day of absence that had
traditionally been people of color would
stay home just so that people would
recognize that like,
oh,
when they're not there,
we missed them and we missed their
contributions.
And they're an important part of our
community.
I think that's a little silly to stay
home and do that.
But I think it's not a bad thing for
people to recognize that everybody plays
a part.
And if these people feel marginalized,
give them a little extra juice and
that's fine.
But the real hardcore social justice
warriors decided that's not enough.
Instead what we want is all white people
to stay home.
And like you can't do that.
And of course is the,
now you're telling people to stay home
versus allowing people to stay home in
which a case you missed them.
This is the opposite.
You're telling these white people to
fuck off.
So Brett,
who is like a fiercely progressive
person,
was telling people like,
you are making a mistake here.
You're getting out of line.
This is not the way to do it.
Right.
And then they went crazy and fucking
looking for him
with baseball bats.
And they,
you know,
they,
they literally kidnapped classes.
They held a teacher,
they held the principal,
uh,
or the president of the school in this
room.
And even when he,
they went to the bathroom,
they escorted him to the restroom and
then brought him back to the room and
they wouldn't let people leave.
The stories are amazing.
Not mean fed that stuff.
He's complete batshit crazy line.
Right.
That shit crazy.
We completely agree on that.
It's like that is ridiculous.
That has no place anywhere.
That's bullshit that you don't do.
Stuff like that is just same thing as
like,
you know to Jordan Peterson thing in
Toronto,
that policy wall,
just stupid policy and he was right in
our going against it.
So I'm not arguing that those are that
they are wrong.
Now I know you're not know you're not
there.
Right.
My issue is from there to wire green
that dcs the super prevalent thing.
It's like from one story or one study
there to say instead,
you know there's a communist conspiracy
to brainwash us all.
It's like,
okay,
what we are starting from a completely
understandable prime and taking it like
25 steps too far.
Yeah,
I agree.
But I think that what's happening is
more of these unusual situations are
occurring and so people were terrified
of this spreading like wildfire across
the country because kids are very easily
influenced,
you know,
and there are also idealistic,
they,
they wanna change the world.
Maybe they grew up with a father was an
asshole and a racist and like fuck this,
no racism,
no fascism and they're calling everybody
that Nazi and running down the street.
But that's,
you have it as a question,
not as a something I'm sure of.
But what I want that is our motto of
daisies,
media,
media fueled and now matches the real
[inaudible].
He yelled for sure.
My question is how much is some,
well,
there's most certainly media influences
people in it influences people in a
bunch of different ways.
It shows that you can get attention for
doing certain things.
It shows that other people were in
support of maybe what you thought were
your radical ideas and then you find
other radical people as well.
But I mean that's also the argument for
not publishing the name of school
shooters.
Right?
It's because a lot of these people think
that this is media fueled by people that
are seeking attention.
And I,
I think they're probably right and
certain in a certain respect,
but it's also just a part of who we are
and I think it makes us really consider
and taking the responsibility,
what is significant about broadcasting
ideas and how much influence these ideas
have on people who absorb them.
For sure.
Take them in for sure.
I think my issue,
it's some of the seeing is that often it
becomes a power thing.
It become Micah when your guys do that
and they showed those totalitarian
sinks,
then boo bath authoritarians.
When my guys,
the way turn the other way in Bhutan is
not true to me in fact is not a one
particular ideology or neither.
It kind of goes back to what you were
saying about human nature in general,
totalitarianism.
You know,
this idea that you want to control what
people think they are.
Choices is horrible,
but regardless of who's doing it,
and in that case,
nobody has a monopoly on this because
you have seen a hardcore religious
fundamentalists push totalitarianism,
you have seen Harlem,
you know eight day study biology like
communism pushing totalitarian.
Yeah,
completely right.
You see people on the political left
report on the political right.
Everybody has,
it's a virus.
You know it's a viral self.
The mind that when he took over there's
this desire squall shola their choices
and I find it equally horrible that
regardless of who's doing it,
you know I'm a little suspicious of
wearing the narrative becomes Luca dose
guys doing it and you're only picking
one side.
It's like there are some guys where I
see even in the desperately try to be
like,
no,
I'm fair.
Look,
I pick on my,
I was listening to somebody doing this
thing.
I think it was more rightwing Korea
entered and he was saying,
Oh this time we are wrong.
And I was like,
oh look at that.
That's kind of a self critique.
That's interesting.
Let me listen.
We are wrong because we are just like
the left and you should hear what the
left at the and then for the next half
hour he goes on about the left and I'm
like,
that's not seth Godin.
He sees a motherfucker.
You're stele parties on shale know.
That's like not been honest to me and
that I think what bugs me is when it's
an ideological battle,
when you want to score points as opposed
to saying,
look,
there are certain scenes that are fucked
up that are evil totalitarianism,
regardless of we charge a is attached to
it is bad.
How about we agree on that?
You know,
that's,
that's kind of where sometime I feel a
little sketch in the way the narrative
gets pushed that it become semi tribe
versus your tribe thing.
Well,
you would probably know better than most
because you've been teaching in
universities for so long.
I mean you would see that you're on the
battlefield.
I think a lot of what it is is a lot of
what you were talking about before about
people doing horrific things is that
they're cowards and they just give in to
the whims of those around them and the
mob mentality.
And I think that happens with the right
wing ideology that you see expressed in
horrific ways.
Like,
you know,
whether it's uh,
I mean fill in the blank.
It could be Charlottesville shall be any
of these horrific things that have
happened where right wing people got
together and protested versus what
happens with the left.
I think it's a lot of it is just people
wanting to be a part of a group.
People wanting to be a part of this,
uh,
this thing that gives them,
they have this feeling of being in a
tribe and solidarity and then they go
along with whatever the ideology is that
tribes pushing.
And that to me is such a danger because
he's,
you know,
that sense of belonging is something
that all human beings crave to one
degree or another.
And sweets.
The same thing that make people join
cults is the same thing that make people
join some hardcore political position is
the same thing that make people join
biker guy.
It's the same mentality,
right?
Is we need to,
as our [inaudible] group with the same
clothes,
with the same idea as we stand for,
because it feels good to have other
people who embrace he was one of them or
three t well as a result,
but of course the price to pay is your
individuality because you have to kind
of sacrifice the complexity of who you
are in order to fit in neatly into this
box.
Yeah,
and you kind of have to,
you have to shut out objectivity because
if you,
if you look at things objectively,
you're going to say,
well,
we're fucked up too and this is,
this doesn't make any sense on why these
aren't my enemy.
They're just people that are on a bad
path like Saigon down on a,
I could have gone down that road too if
I lived over in that community and I've
found myself in this one spot that leans
left and so I'm leaning left to right.
Yeah.
Well how does that stop though?
This is my question about all that kind
of stuff.
Like what could ever happen?
What could you foresee happening in
history where people could look past
that and sort of figure it out and go,
you know what?
There has gotta be a better way to
behave and think,
and this is probably one of our main
concerns because if you really look at
what if you ask people what's our main
concern?
Well,
war.
Okay,
sure.
Uh,
the economy,
that's,
that's big.
And then you know,
and there's a host of other things that
bothered people,
crime and education and all these
different things.
Well,
what,
what is causing all of this conflict?
What is,
what is causing it?
Well,
a giant percentage of what we're talking
about is some sort of a weird tribal
behavior.
Or you get a get a group,
you become a part of that group and then
that's what you identify with.
So that's what you reinforce and then
you get some sort of Brownie points for
reinforcing the ideologies of that
group.
And you,
you know,
if you're the most rabid person years,
the Steve Bannon of that group,
everybody rises up and gets behind you.
This motherfuckers at the front of the
line.
Exactly supporting our values.
And then you know,
you find these communities online where
people just,
they're constantly signaling to all
these other people in that group that
they're supporting this ideology and
they get all these likes and me like I
feel like likes on twitter and on
instagram and stuff like that.
I feel like that's shaping people's
opinions and behavior way more than
anyone has taken into consideration.
I mean even the fact that you know,
the algorithms,
make sure that you only see the stuff
that you are already click like.
So you start seeing the same threads
over and over the same topics.
You'd really is creating echo chambers
and that's really not good.
It's fucking horrible.
You know,
it's weird and it's weird what people
like and what people don't like.
A lot of of people like is just really
stupid.
I mean how many girls are getting fake
asses just for likes on instagram?
I know it's probably a lot.
Right?
Definitely.
It's a very,
very interesting time for human beings.
I feel like for you as a person who is
deeply knowledgeable about history and
you study history and you have this
history podcast,
and when you look at today,
do you ever try to look at today in a
perspective of someone in the future
trying to teach about today?
Yeah,
and the thing is that as much as there
are obviously cycles in history and
there are patterns that are recognizable
and all of that two days or so,
so damn unique because if you look at,
just forgot everything got us.
If you look at the way just technology
has shaped does the last hundred and 50
years are unlike the previous 200,000
DRC.
You know the stuff that has happened in
the last time,
they're 50 years from electricity,
the refrigerator or Internet radio,
TV.
It's like the pace of technological
development is something that nobody has
ever even come close in human history
before.
So we are in a place where it's where
really an uncharted territory where the,
the human mind has evolved so much from
one where happy monkeys running around,
but we are now,
we have these tools to do stuff that we
are really not prepared to deal with to
a large degree and Swiss,
kind of a big open question I how,
where do we go from here?
Because there's no previous model that
you can say,
well that one time,
3000 years ago when they invented the
Internet,
they handled it this way.
It's like there's nothing like it.
You know,
the tools we have are,
our disposals are unlike anything that
has ever happened before.
So that's how the case is sort of,
you know,
usually he is three.
You can see,
oh you learned this lesson.
You can definitely learn about human
nature and how the human mind works.
But then from that you have to predict
how the human mind will be applied to a
context that's unlike anything,
any other contests that ever faced does
before.
And then the big concern is that the
human mind will create an artificial
mind that won't take into consideration
any of the previous cultural ideals that
we've supported and just go run rampant.
Yup.
The Darpa has created an a robot that
I've been raving about.
It drives me crazy.
It's called the eater robot.
I t.
R.
It,
uh,
it operates on biological material,
meaning it fee is fueled by eating
bodies.
Okay.
What could possibly go wrong with that?
The idea is that on the battlefield,
I'm sure they're not talking about this,
they've conveniently left this,
like one of the things that,
well it may be you could eat plants,
maybe you could eat a rabbit or
something or maybe give you fucking
people.
Like my,
my number one concern with all this
stuff is that I think it's happening so
fast and so many things are taking place
in so many different realms when it
comes to innovation that this stuff will
just catch up to us before we even
recognize it's happened.
And it will be too late for sure.
I mean,
even just forget every single us,
even just the whole,
uh,
atomic bomb.
See Schlau for the last ever since we
started from the 1940 still today,
there have been some seriously close
calls.
There was a,
um,
I remember to one that was wanting the
1980s,
I think right before the end of the Cold
War where there was,
you know,
Russia,
the guy to his boring job where they're
supposed to look for missiles from the
United States and nothing ever happened
day after day after day.
And I,
one day there's a bleep on the radar and
you're like,
oh shit.
And he's the guy,
he's jaw,
but to Cooley superiors.
And then if he does the old site,
they are going to press the button.
And he's like,
no,
no.
Wait,
let's come down.
Maybe this wrong.
I made a concern,
not that stupid.
They will not send one atomic bomb if
they'd do it,
they send a bunch.
So these must be a mistake.
Let's hold that.
I relax 30 minutes later and other bleep
and other beliefs and other,
but he was like,
oh shit,
they are set and you get a bunch of
atomic bombs.
This is the real deal.
And the Guy Steele doesn't do what he's
supposed to.
He's feels like if I make this call,
nuclear war starts,
I need to be [inaudible] was in percent
convenience.
The evidence in front of them is pretty
solid,
but I still don't feel it.
And then five minutes later,
all the beliefs go off.
It was a mistake on the radar and there
was like some random bleep and uh,
the guy promptly there and get bottle of
vodka straight because he was like,
you know,
the almost caused world war three.
Exactly.
And you know,
most of us all their lives now,
some Russian dude in the 1980s who
decided not to do what he was supposed
to and then the old because of this
stupid mistake,
stupid bug in the radar.
That's,
that's when you know that the
technologies we have are way too much
for our decision make or way.
Not enough because it should be exactly
that.
That's the other side.
Nothing.
I mean what,
was it a flock of birds or was it,
I don't even know what the thing,
yeah,
that's,
that kind of shit terrifies me.
It's just the ability to do something
like that without the,
the understanding or the discipline to
create it is really nuts.
I always liken it to like giving a baby
a gun.
Like the baby didn't figure out how to
use that gun.
They didn't invent it.
They don't know how to load a around,
but they can just fucking pull that
trigger.
But by,
Yup.
And people can die that that can happen.
People get killed by toddlers all the
time.
People leave their person there and
their bag,
toddler picks it up,
shoots himself.
Shoot someone else happens over at the
time.
All the time.
Yeah.
It's um,
human beings have access to all sorts of
technologies that we would never be able
to figure it out on our own.
Yeah.
And we don't,
we with those great with the great
responsibility that comes with using
those things.
There should be some sort of great
knowledge that you have to acquire about
the thing itself.
Like some sort of some reasonable
facsimile of like what it took to create
that thing.
[inaudible] like some deep intensive
program like,
Hey,
you want to,
you want to learn how to drive a car.
Like this is how an engine was
developed.
This is,
this is how breaks work this out and
you've got to know you can't half ass
this or right.
You know,
the same should be said about guns.
Same should be said about everything.
We just have access to too much shit
that we would never be able to figure
out on our own.
Yeah.
And we're like,
wow,
this is fucking try it.
You press that button,
see what happens.
Yeah.
Old might be or approach to saying
societies like learn how to you was he?
Then we can talk about,
yeah,
they keep coming up with new ones in
Russia.
Come up with some new super sonic
missile like it just a few days ago they
announced it.
The better off.
You're better off not hearing about it.
It was Katie stuff with little,
uh,
you know,
old your old,
the guest on the gre will be,
or in your compound that we'd float
tanks and stuff to survive depaul
collapse when the zombies attack.
You don't want to be a survivor.
I mean you maybe one of your ancestors
to survive,
so he should survive.
But you answered,
she's might get raped and eaton,
right.
It all says off.
Surviving doesn't look like a fun one.
Yeah.
Right.
Like if you were around in Indonesia
70,000 years ago when the big one blue
and you were one of the survivors and
you're,
you know,
picking through the wreckage of
civilization,
not good times stuff.
Anyway,
man.
But then again,
if it wasn't for them,
we wouldn't have Disneyland.
If we chase it,
bang part,
I'm calling.
Yes.
It wasn't for them.
No netflix.
Nope.
It wasn't for them.
No iphone because of people in
Indonesia.
Yes,
because those people did eat those dead
people because those people did figure
out a way to somehow or another get
enough nutrients from whatever the fuck
they ate to compensate for the fact they
were involved in nuclear winter.
That's not man.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
And it's,
but it makes you realize,
which is we the people that are
listening to this,
the people that are alive today,
we're not going to make it.
It's just we are not going to make it
like everyone's so hopeful that the
human race is gonna make it.
And that's one of the reasons why we
have offspring and loved ones and
friends.
And even if I'm gone,
I want everyone else to be happy.
You know,
I had a great time while I'm here.
Don't cry for me,
but no one's making it.
They're not going to make it either.
You're just prolonging their life.
Like everyone's life is going to come to
a wall.
Everyone loud the game works.
But we're cool with that.
We're cool with grandma dying.
Grandma died,
but she was 97 years old when she died.
She was a wonderful woman and she was
loved by many.
Everybody's cool with that.
You know,
we're not cool with everybody dying all
at once.
Yeah.
That's,
this is the end of the experiment.
This is the end of the process.
Fuck no,
it's not the end.
It's just we're going to,
everyone's going to die and then we're
going to restart with monkeys.
It's going to take another few million
years,
but the chimps would eventually become
people.
Again,
it's a,
it's kind of what I am saying is that if
anybody's going to survive is going to
be the people are leaving close to
hunting and gathering conditions today
that are seen as you know,
the most backward people in the ward are
the ones who actually have a shelter
that making 18 a short apocalyptic
situation.
Yeah.
Like people in the Amazon or something
like that.
They're,
they're probably the only ones that have
a chance.
Yup.
What's up mad at Jamie?
Do you see this going around the story
about this new company that can upload
your brain,
but it kills you?
What a startup is pitching a mind
uploading service that is 100% fatal.
I think they're taking like people that
are already terminal patients and
whatnot.
That's their first sort of,
and they to upload their mind.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I didn't,
they're going to give you some bullshit
scrambled version of what your,
it's going to be all swa stickers like,
like we found grandpa's brain and a,
we're going to upload it now and you'll
be able to look into his thoughts out.
It's all dicks.
GRANDPA's,
all Dixon and Nazi memorabilia.
Preserve your brain uploaded company.
It's chemical solution can keep a body
intact for hundreds of years,
maybe thousands as a statue of frozen
glass.
What the idea is that some day in the
future scientists will scan your bricked
brain and turn it into a computer
simulation so they didn't even know how
to do it yet.
This is bullshit that way someone liked
a lot like you though.
Not Exactly.
You will smell the flowers again in a
data server somewhere.
What?
Okay.
The stories that grizzly twist though
for NEC tomes procedure to work,
it's essential that the brain be fresh.
The company says its plan is to connect
people with terminal illnesses to a
heart lung machine in order to pump it's
mix of scientific and bombing chemicals
into the big cardioid arteries in their
next,
well,
they'll still alive though under general
anesthesia.
Thank God you put them under before you
kill him.
Cause we will want them to experience
any pain for they go into the great
frozen glass statue beyond,
there's a waiting list,
of course is a waiting list.
A bunch of fucking idiots.
Jesus Christ.
People are stupid.
Uh,
there's uh,
you know,
hundreds of thousands of people signed
up to die on Mars.
Do you know that?
To have the opportunity to be one of the
first people to die on Mars,
hundreds of thousands of people signed
up.
Yeah.
You don't want to be the first to be
locked in a space ship for six months
with a bunch of other people.
So fucking stupid.
They're willing to die on Mars.
Yeah.
Then you get there.
They're just talking about social
justice the entire way,
all,
all the way over there.
Talking about veganism and social
justice and,
oh man.
Yeah.
Elon Musk on first Mars explorer as good
chance you'll die or chance.
How about a hundred percent you're going
to die with you.
Stay here,
stay here.
I get good chance you'll die.
Your die.
Everyone's dying.
You're going to die.
That's the fucked up thing.
We just don't want everybody to die all
at once.
We're cool with small groups.
People that are brown that die in caves
on the other part of the world.
If we could be convinced they're
primitive,
they hold these ridiculous beliefs and
a,
we don't even know them.
Right,
so we're just going to kill them with
robots.
Yeah.
It's somebody out there.
Oh cares.
It's not us.
Yeah.
I think just the rate of change is
happening so fast.
It's going to be a lot of dumb shit like
this.
It happens along the way.
Of course,
like the bell bottoms of technology.
It's like what is the thought fuck were
they thinking and it's just going to
keep,
keep happening like that.
It's,
I mean you think about even most of the
stuff that we do today,
like which foods are okay to eat and
which one's not?
How many people like to go,
oh look at that.
Greg is gone.
He had the wrong plants,
so let's make an older,
we do not eat that plant.
Yeah,
we share.
That's all greg eight.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's like they should still eat it.
Let's try one more time.
Get my to eat it.
Yeah.
He's got an iron stomach.
The duties,
old carcasses and shit.
They had to like express it somehow or
another in a way that everybody would
remember it too.
Probably in songs and shit.
Yep.
Yeah,
cause exactly.
That's the other thing I would do.
You pass information in a society that's
not liter at and yet people did it.
I mean,
when you think about things like the
[inaudible] or the all they say they
don't know these long gas compositions
completely passed down orally,
you know,
without,
by the time they wrote down was saying
to this down the road.
It's like that's some protein,
same thing that humans were able to do
in like memorize all this stuff.
Yeah.
Really it's saying,
you know,
I was thinking the other day about songs
like how crazy the technology of
remembering things through songs are.
Cause if like he didn't go all the songs
you could sing along to the words.
Now think of how many poems that you can
recite.
It's like very few or stories that you
can,
what poems?
Maybe because they rhyme,
but reciting a story verbatim.
Almost none.
Very few.
But like we were a,
at the common story the other day,
we were talking about,
um,
grammar and sentence structure and stuff
like that.
And uh,
I brought up those,
uh,
ABC afterschool things like conjunction
junction.
What's your function hook and up words
and phrases and clauses.
Like,
you know what it is like,
you know,
I'm just a bill sitting here on Capitol
Hill and like they explain these things
in a way that you could remember fucking
decades later.
You would never remember.
You would never remember if it wasn't
for those things.
There was a guy named Ariosa was like
one of these,
uh,
like back when they had the council of
nicea and they kind of decided what is
real Christianity going to be a while we
decided to be the fake stuff.
Ariosa was on the losing side,
but part of the theme that meeting
seemingly popular is that he put on all
this theology and songs.
Exactly like what you're saying.
It would be super complicated thing
about,
you know,
Jesus bees kind of like God the father
but not really and Dah,
Dah,
really brainy stuff.
Puto like a silly song that the guy
would sing while he's baking bread and
stuff.
And so he was closely Paul polar because
he figured that's how people pick up
stuff.
It is up.
People pick up stuff,
you know what I mean?
To this day,
right.
Like pronouns.
I think that that song pronouns take the
place of a noun cause saying all those
nouns over and over can really wear you
down.
They need a
missed too many days.
That's cool.
Good job that,
that stuff for whatever reason sticks of
course.
I wonder why like making things rhyme
and and putting them in song has a
particular profound effect on your
memory.
Yeah,
it is funny cause even when you look at
babies,
you know they respond to music so much.
They have that immediate like Sam
sounds,
that clique with the developing mind
have a baby.
You don't need to have culture.
You don't need to have knowledge.
You don't need to have as baby.
You can still pick up seeing and
remembered.
I mean yeah or sometime you know,
somebody put some music and one note to
goes into babies immediately recognize
it.
Just like I know what this is is that's
the one I enjoy.
And as you do it the other day,
by the way is fucking hilarious.
Was in the,
in Italy,
it is a,
he's this little kid is probably two or
three are sold and the dad keeps trying
to play like children song and the
baby's pissed off and he's like no,
no,
no.
And he's like what do you all and thank
you say something and the dad is like
okay fine,
we'll do this again.
And whole Lotta love by led Zeppelin
started the baby just lights up is so
happy.
He's like yes.
So we are talking about,
it would be amazing if that kid grows up
to be like a big rock star.
Right?
Imagine you know what I mean?
The whole lot of love and he's a baby
palm,
a bound bound back,
CSAC.
I don't know.
That's to me is like I kind of did that
a lot with my daughter cause I'm like I
hate to do this to you but you are my
daughter and I want to listen to good
shape.
I don't want to listen to stupid baby
stuff all the time.
So it's like even to this day,
like she goes to bad,
we tend the exit like there's,
then drake says a Lula by of course the
mellow and rex was the hardcore stuff is
for the day,
but like at night when she want to go to
sleep,
I'll put on like the more metal or
seeing like when Andrew is playing
acoustic guitar or like [inaudible] or
something like that that I like that I
can tolerate.
Don't give me any baby shit stuff cause
I just,
I mean right now she's not a baby,
but even when she was little I'm like,
sorry I can't do that like it though.
The thing about baby stuff is like
babies like baby stuff or even little
kids,
like little kid stuff.
Like my kids,
like a lot of really fucking dumb shows,
but they love them.
It's like what can you do?
Can you say no,
you can't love that because it's too
fucking stupid,
but it's not stupid to them.
I can tolerate it.
If we balance it with something else,
I'm like,
okay,
that's fine.
I get it.
It's part of your developmental stage.
Good for you,
but give me something here.
Okay,
let,
let's find a middle ground here.
Or we can listen to the same music or
watch something like,
and that's where I recognize I may have
done irreparable damage to my offspring
because I realized the other day we
watch a movie and my daughters come and
to basically say this is the coolest
thing ever was like it says good as
Conan the barbarian.
That I was like,
yes,
I'm glad you were my daughter.
Was she talking about the books?
I was just talking about the movie
though.
Hold off.
And she like,
she loves the,
you know,
the one corner and that was [inaudible]
now the 1982 one of course.
See I read their old,
the t our stories and wow.
You know,
I changed the language slightly cause
sometime in the language is a little
like you need to really have a crazy
vocabulary for an eight year olds.
You're not going to pick it up.
So I kind of tweak it a lethal,
but then,
you know,
all the good stuff is there and uh,
I feel like the best Conan could have
been Jason Momoa.
They just gave him a shit movie.
The script was like,
my mind is so good.
He's very good.
He looks like a fucking barbarian,
like you believe it.
Perfect big giant guy.
And he's also not built like a
bodybuilder.
He's just built like a guy who was in
really good shape,
which you would think Conan would be
there he is.
Right.
I think he was the best Konan he's
seemed to me to be the most realistic.
Maybe could he use a little bit more gym
time,
but not nothing crazy.
But the problem you had this crepes,
that's something that's anti frustrates
me when you see like all the elements
are there and the screenwriting socks
says like,
come on man.
Sucks.
Just straight dog shit.
But he was fucking great as Conan.
Like you believed it.
Yup.
No,
he just looked evil enough and it looked
like a guy who really was a sword
fighter who really did live in that era.
Whereas Conan played by Arnold
Schwarzenegger.
You're like,
wait a minute,
what's the guy's got no armpit hair.
It's completely shaved down.
Built like a brick shit.
I was like,
it just,
it was freakishly big.
Yeah.
That's actually a picture.
He looks fairly reasonable there.
All right.
Go to layer to think about new,
it's actually quite a bit leaner and
those days that he was in his
bodybuilder day.
Yeah.
That one was just all so,
but he was still,
there's definitely to do,
it had been doing some bench pressing.
It wasn't someone just swine club bells
around and I mean he didn't get those
muscles just by pushing the wheel of
pain.
That was part of it too.
Right.
There's definitely that.
A little bit of that too.
Oh Man.
On that note,
I've been,
um,
the last couple of years I've been
playing a lot in that world with
screenwriting and stuff.
I'm so excited with that.
I'm just getting,
cause you know the thing that I enjoy
like in [inaudible] on fire and stuff
like that at historic tiling and I
realize I ended up doing that in
whatever field I'm,
you know,
whether when I'm teaching,
most of it is storytelling.
When um,
history on fire is storytelling.
And so I started playing a little,
it's getting writings because I had good
hookups man.
I'm having so much fun.
It's like when you're writing,
well there's the stuff that looks,
there are a few,
like they are all mostly historical
fiction kind of stories and one of them
right now look really damn promising but
they have threatened me to chop off my
bowls and nailed them two or three if I
talk about it so I can really bring it
up because that one actually has a shot
at making it a okay.
There are others seeing swear.
I'm much more kind of early development.
Like for example,
Oh I saw you got outside the Frank
Frazetta painting.
Yeah.
So Satta the granddaughter of Frank
Wants to develop one of the,
one of the characters that are
[inaudible] girls.
She's the one who does it all right,
Shannon.
Yeah,
she's awesome.
She's super sweet.
And,
and I,
and she started asking,
you know,
I showed them some of my writing were
chatting.
She liked it.
And so she wanted me to develop like one
of those characters are seen to,
uh,
create a ward around it,
like a game of thrones,
meat,
corn and kind of thing.
And I'm like,
that's what you're asking of you to do
or you see that's like the dream job
ever.
It's like hell yeah,
I want to play with that.
That sounded like fun.
It will be epic.
So I think those movies and those shows
when done correctly,
when executed correctly,
are some of the most entertaining
compelling things,
whether it's game of thrones or Lord of
the rings or this is the Conan ones were
just an arnold did a great job and those
are fun.
But they're campy.
Yeah.
I mean the first one was good.
The other ones were painful.
They were reading.
I represent Robert Howard's don't work.
Don't already,
Howard's work is still to this day.
Never really,
totally been captured.
Yeah.
I yard at Amazon is going to be doing a
corner and see it is,
I don't know.
They're not going to fuck.
Maybe they are,
if they're doing it,
who's going to play Kona?
And I have no idea.
I don't think they peaked dts cause I do
would have announced it.
I think they were just saying it seemed
available.
Mains they are gonna try to stick to a
rubber t our stories.
So who knows.
Let's see.
But we got the shackles.
They could pull out the big money.
Get Jason Mamoa to get back in the hunt.
I know that he's the Kona and I think
you made the guy,
he's like six foot three.
He's built like a brick shit house.
Yeah,
he looks like he would be a barbarian.
Like you looks perfect.
Like when he paid call drago that was
perfect.
He was perfect.
Yeah.
You buy it.
You see him playing that role.
You're like,
oh I buy that.
He's a savage.
He would be awesome if they did that
man.
That would be epic.
Yeah.
There's a a day or doing a bunch of
stuff there.
Do we and dad,
they are doing it but equal to Lord of
the rings on Amazon's.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ that Jeff Bezos guys got a
little too much cash.
Hey,
I'm old for it.
Like do one more.
Yeah.
Do it all.
Look,
I mean it's just,
I mean he,
they have that really good billy Bob
Thornton show too that people see me
about.
I haven't seen it either,
but people,
what is it called again?
That billy Bob Thornton show on Amazon?
Uh,
Jamie,
you'll find it.
Sure.
I don't,
I don't know what it's called,
but I know that people keep raving about
it.
Aliah Goliath.
Thank you.
Yeah.
It's supposed to be really good.
And you know the problem with those,
here's what's weird.
More than half the households in this
country have Amazon.
I think Amazon prime.
Yup.
Like right.
It's like 51% of the households.
But how many people are actually
watching those Amazon videos?
That's a good question.
I think once they start booking these
kind of money on some of these big
shows,
the odds that that percentage is going
to grow,
it's pretty damn high.
Let's find out this,
I don't know if Amazon releases their
numbers.
They don't do they do it?
Probably not.
But did they do it the same way?
You don't know.
Um,
Google,
uh,
see if,
what,
how many people watch Goliath on Amazon?
Maybe we'll find out because date no one
has any idea how many people are
watching things on netflix other than
Netflix and Netflix.
They just,
they don't tell anybody nothing and
clearly must be a good number because
they keep producing shows booked of mine
in it.
So you know that it's working for them.
Well,
what they do know is how many people
have subscribed to Netflix and that's an
insane,
huge number.
But the actual number of people that
watch every,
they don't tell you shit.
Like,
I have a comedy special on Netflix.
They don't tell you nothing.
They go,
great job.
We like it.
You have no idea.
Like you like it.
Why?
Oh,
it's great.
People love it.
Okay,
well how many people love it?
Oh,
lots.
No fucking,
they don't give you any data,
which they don't have to.
And maybe that's good.
Maybe people concentrate too much on the
numbers.
You know what I mean?
Like someone was saying that the Oscars
this year,
uh,
the Oscars this year are down by you
know,
5 million people.
They still got washed by 25 million
people.
Cause I'm like,
what?
What do we do in here?
Like who cares?
Why is that even a thing?
Because that's why we've been
concentrating on that.
I can't find the viewers but they,
this is the kind of information they
give out is the top Bin,
first season of a US produce Amazon
original series ever over its first 10
days.
That doesn't mean shit.
Yeah.
No other season,
no other season one had a higher season
completion rate through 10 days.
Well that's interesting.
That must mean it's a really good show.
So people binged it the first season.
Can you get Amazon prime on a I on apple
TV,
the other part of Apple TV because I'm
always,
or do you have to get one of those fire
sticks?
I can watch it through my teeth.
My TV has a thing,
has a smart tv app on it that I can get
it through there.
And it says it arrived on Apple TV in
over a hundred countries as of December.
So yeah.
Oh so last December.
December of 2017 yes.
Okay.
So we have it now.
Hmm.
But still netflix is just so much more
popular.
It's like cue tips once it like becomes
the name.
Like give me a box.
Q tips.
Do you want cotton swabs?
No,
motherfucker.
I said q tip.
You know,
it's like,
dude,
do you want to watch streaming video and
want to watch Netflix?
We have Amazon streaming video,
bitch net flicks.
Did I stutter?
Netflix only took over that recently.
Right?
Because give me a fucking iphone.
It used to be their bullshit fake
smartphone nonsense.
Ivivva yeah,
it's pretty recent.
Yeah,
just mailed before.
Like they took over blockbuster first
and then they're like,
and now it's all streaming.
Yeah.
You can still get dvds I think,
but I don't know how many I do cause I'm
a nerd.
You get dvds still.
Really?
Cause they don't have the same
offerings.
Their staff that they do have on DVD
that they don't have on streaming and
vice versa.
So like for example,
what was I watching?
It was,
um,
I think at the last season of Vikings
for example,
I think that's why I fine.
I've been watching it now I'm season
two.
It's good.
That's the good,
you know,
it kind of don't tell me that.
Don't tell me it goes down hill.
I'll fucking go crazy.
There's two seasons are awesome,
son of a [inaudible] game of thrones
that way through Netflix for instance.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You can rent the dvds of game of
thrones,
exact shit,
punch it through their streaming app,
but you could only get game of thrones
dvds.
Yup.
Yeah.
But you're paying the next year,
like what,
10 bucks a month to rent those and send
it.
That's how they used,
that's what Netflix was when it started,
you know,
one,
two,
three dvds a month or whenever.
We're at a time.
Weird.
So netflix dvds has game of thrones.
Netflix streaming does not exactly
everything for any DVD you can get.
Yeah,
that's weird.
They had a lot more on dvds.
Then they have just streaming there a
bunch of stuff that I want to watch like
case in point you have game of thrones
and Viking.
Some of that stuff is uh,
I used to freak out and not having a
physical DVD player in my laptop.
Like this is ridiculous.
So I bought one of those ones that plugs
in.
Yeah,
I've never used it once.
Sat there is by are just in watching
Orleans stream,
you know,
download them from itunes and then they
sit on my laptop.
I don't,
yeah,
it's,
this is all so new but yet we're so
convinced that this is what this is the
future,
right?
This is it.
Netflix period.
Everybody else fuck off.
It's locked in.
I think they're doing comedy specials on
Amazon as well.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure Amazon prime did Bob
Saget new special and a few other
people.
Then that's one of the cool things
because Amazon is trying to compete with
Netflix,
so they are trying to come up.
So they're going to put an insane amount
of money and show his,
and he's got eight for content because
there's today there's probably more
possibilities for people doing stuff
that never before there where before you
had only so many studios producing only
so many movies.
Now there's so much more.
Brian counts on there.
Joey Diaz is on there.
Brian's on Netflix.
Jim burrs on Netflix.
Um,
who else?
Tom Papa.
I'm Securitas old one.
Yeah,
Eddie pepitone.
Oh Wow.
Greg Fitzsimmons.
So there's quite a few specials that are
available on Amazon.
Jim Norton.
Very interesting.
That might be where the,
what was that one that just closed that?
Um,
yeah,
CSO.
Yeah.
Maybe they just,
they have a lot of them on there now.
Yeah,
I bet that's exactly what it is.
Yeah.
Interesting.
It says continue watching or watching
the beginning.
That means that Jamie Vernon was
watching it.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Um,
I hope it works.
I mean,
I would love to see a bunch of different
viable outlets for people to release
films and TV shows and stuff like that.
And God knows Netflix has enough money.
I know they,
any sodas,
the Amazon,
they have ton of fucking money.
Yeah.
Apple's not doing that though.
They're going to try to do that.
Create original stuff that they have
that one,
a Jennifer Aniston and reese show that's
coming out soon.
Look at me.
I had a game show or not game show,
but planet of the apps with like,
when is pouch row will I am Gary Vee was
on that trying to get me throw up,
not Gary V.
I mean,
they haven't all necessarily been
successful,
but they're trying,
I'm just kidding about throwing out.
If you're a gallon year to those ladies,
just don't listen to me.
I'm just fucking,
just make it fun.
Yeah,
I think it's good.
I mean,
I would like to see more.
Um,
I just think in terms of like your
ability to sit down and do absolutely
fucking nothing and zone out for days,
there's never been a better time
[inaudible] there's so much stuff
available.
Apple is reportedly investing 1 billion
in original video content.
Wow.
Jesus Christ.
Okay,
so appellees add that to the mix and
that's Gary v with a big old smile on
his face.
How does that Guy Sleep?
Talk does,
how's he?
Where's he,
where's he at the time I'm pretty busy
but that's what that guy,
exactly what people ask about you is
like how does he manage to to like 72
carriers in one and an old hunting and
workout and duties and that is like,
oh I don't know.
I think human cloning or like really
three Joe Rogan's going around that
there are like you have downloaded your
consciousness in three d for baldies
were doing some of this stuff.
One of them would fuck up hardcore if I
did that.
Like it's,
it's hard enough to manage my insanity
with one life,
five,
three lives going on.
One of them are definitely go off the
rails with I think is what I do is it's
more of a,
it's an illusion that I'm as busy as
people think I am.
It's not as busy.
It is busy,
but it's less busy with work than people
think because the podcast is,
you know,
sitting here with a friend like you and
talk for a few hours,
it's pretty easy.
That's not really that hard.
And then the working out,
well that's just mandatory.
Just have to go around and then there's
the standup comedy.
Well that's kind of a passion project
and it's interesting and I do it all the
right.
Like I know avid timed down like,
oh hang out with my family,
tell my kids,
go to bed,
which is usually like,
you know,
eight ish and that's when I leave.
Right.
Then I go to the comedy store.
Like I know I've have it pretty much
locked in.
I get my podcast done before the kids
get home from school,
so I'm hanging out with them.
I know how to do it.
I'm working out while they're at school
for the most part.
But it impressive though because that
means you have cause you every,
at least until you do have so much stuff
on your plate and the way you make it
flow.
There's that something in terms of time
management,
I think there will be people willing to
take courses from you on how to put it
all together because that's a skill
right there.
You have to be really steadfast in what
you want to do and what you don't want
to do.
And when you don't want to do something,
just don't do it right.
But that,
I wasn't able to do this until I really
started working for myself,
like working for myself and the ability
to wait.
If you have a bunch of different jobs
but you're beholden to other people's
schedules,
it's almost on manager.
Yeah.
It's up and you can't do it.
But,
uh,
that's why I would assume I'm trying to
do,
I'm trying to,
as much
as I enjoy being in the classroom,
I'm trying to be in the classroom with
less and less,
just do more online and do more Paul
customer because I'm tired of being in
somebody else's,
you know?
Imagine if you like driving.
It's like I don't mind if you put me in
the classroom and that's great,
but if I have to drive an hour and a
half to get there and then be stuck in
traffic,
it's like fuck this.
This is just not fun.
Do you feel like there's opportunities,
like real viable opportunities for
people now to get an education online?
Legitimate full education?
It's definitely a merchant.
I mean I think it's a part of the
problem is that the universities kind of
have a monopoly on the diplomas,
which is something that people need for
their job is not the day choose who I
want to be educated.
There are ways to do it is also they
need that piece of paper and of course
so far only the official universities
have that.
But otherwise,
yeah,
there are a bunch of ways.
There's like,
even when,
when was he on like [inaudible] that
he's starting to do his own thing.
His Dad,
something called,
I told him to change the name,
it's called the renegade university.
And I'm like,
stop,
stop.
People are gonna think you're a
douchebag.
He's done.
I've got to do a,
I probably got up to,
I think,
cause he asked me to do these about the
history of martial arts.
I'm like,
Oh man,
I've done [inaudible] that's a course
I've actually done at Ucla.
And it was so much fun.
I taught at Ucla.
Yeah,
check this out.
This was hilarious.
I only had an ami and at Ucla you need a
phd to teach.
And I was like white guy going into an
Asian American studies department and
going,
you know,
yeah.
If case you haven't noticed,
I'm not Asian American and I do all the
Nma and uh,
I never taken a course in Asian American
studies,
but I would love to teach for you and
dee rees why?
And by the time I was done with the
peach about history and philosophy of
martial arts,
they were like,
yeah,
you're a hired,
let's go do it.
And I was like,
okay,
now why would they,
would they want you to be Asian because
you teaching about an agent subject.
I mean they don't want you to,
it kind of works their way because of
the way you know most of the people who
stopped taking a bunch of classes in
ethnic studies.
Usually people who are from that
particular ethnic group you've had,
I'm kind of,
people always look at me like,
Huh,
what's going on here?
Because I do teach in an American Indian
studies department.
I have taught in an Asian American
studies department,
but when you look at everybody else,
usually they are people who are from
that particular ethnic group who are
passionate and to dig in that much to be
in that field.
Is there a,
is that an issue?
Is there like push back?
If you're not,
I mean it's kind of a,
to be fair,
people have been really cool about it
because I mean I've even had the
situation where I taught as pirate of an
ethnic ethnic studies class where they
were like four people,
right?
And there's the African American studies
guys and African American guy in the
Chicano,
Latino,
Latino.
And that was the odd one out,
right?
I was teaching the American Indian
studies section and they're like,
Huh,
you just replaced my friend,
the native lady who the fuck are you?
White guy kind of thing.
But you know,
the thing was they want to check you.
And then once I did my thing,
the first few licensed,
they were like,
Nah,
he's cool.
We like him,
it's all good.
And then there was no bullshit and like
I would have expected to run into a lot
more pushback.
There really wasn't one thing.
And in your favor about when it comes to
martial arts,
although it is mostly Asian in origin,
it varies so widely.
These Chinese marshawn,
Japanese,
Korean,
I mean it goes on and on tie,
there's so many different styles.
And then of course South America,
once Brazilian Jujitsu got into the mix.
Of course they,
in my opinion have revolutionized
martial arts more than any other group.
I think that one part of the country in
South America,
Brazil,
they had more of an impact on martial
arts I think than anyway because they
essentially started,
I mean they started the ultimate
fighting championship just to see if
their martial art was superior.
Yup.
And they proved it to be so it's at
least on its own by itself at first,
you know,
before anybody knew about it.
I think that stuff was a,
there's the whole period from when
Japanese martial arts,
we're kind of crashing because nobody
was dressing as a Samurai anymore,
you know,
doing that stuff didn't make sense
anymore.
And Jiu Jitsu was seen kind of as low
class activity for gain stairs and you
know,
there was less and less popularity for
that field.
And then when did you go to Oakano?
The creator of judo started.
He was these nerdy shopper class guy,
but he was very passionate about judo.
So He transformed the Jujitsu Cori into
judo,
gave it to a whole new spin.
He's like,
no,
it's not this thing to beat people up.
Like all the tags you have seen so far
where using jude was a form of
education.
And then we started that.
Yeah,
it's a super cool story.
And then he starts sending people all
over the world to spread it.
And so they go to Russia and then mix
with Rashaun thing and they create sound
sambo and then come out here and then
with a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu when my,
that goes down to Brazil and all of
that.
So it's like that whole story,
how it's beans is awesome.
And then you end up with the,
the joy of globalization where like when
you see like hallways going to fight
against Sakuraba and you have,
you know,
but as Elian Dude trained in,
uh,
what originally was a Asia martial arts
transformed into this Brazilian thing
wearing ag,
going against getting who was more of a
catch wrestler with studied more through
western wrestling a whole lot.
He goes hilarious.
It's like you have the Japanese guy who
was a more western wrestling back.
It's fun.
That is crazy.
The Japanese especially Sakuraba we're
way influenced by catch wrestling,
but which is American folk style
wrestling.
Yup.
Yeah.
Now I didn't know that,
um,
that Jujitsu was used by thugs.
Yeah.
That was the pirates that he's in
Hawaii,
Japan bashing him polarities because
used to be sort of the Samurai arts,
right.
You do all that stuff.
But then the summer I end that,
you know,
by the 1870s or so,
that was the pulse of the summarize.
So there really wasn't a function for
this stuff anymore.
It's like,
and the only people who trained were
mostly against theirs and kind of rough
guys who train for,
because they got into fights on the
street and then kind.
No,
because he was this kind of secretly
child.
They Puti mean to strain in Jiu Jitsu to
kind of build the map.
Giving me some strand.
Any was a complete nerd,
but he loved Jujitsu and so he's like,
no,
don't put it down.
It's a great heart for other reason.
And he had his old way of spinning it
around to saying that was the old stuff.
Yeah.
To beat people up.
What we do today is a form of education
is a relationship with your body.
Any bicycle.
He invented a new function for it.
So the Japanese society went,
Oh shit,
we can still do that stuff and now
there's a better reason for it.
That's 15 the times.
That's not the same reason why we would
train in the 17 hundreds right.
These actually fit the context of our
time.
Okay.
Let's the judo and then do they have
texts where you could see the techniques
or where you could see what
similarities?
Yeah.
There are both English in Jujitsu,
Manuel's where there are,
you know,
the drawings and stuff like that.
And then by the time of comes around,
they even start diving fruitage after a
while.
Right.
Footage of actual films of you
utilization that they,
lord drills.
They look goofy as hell because they're
sped up and the move from the and stuff.
But they,
uh,
yeah,
there's good stuff and some of those
guys are just bad asses from day one.
I mean some of the old judo guys,
they got the reputation for just being
killers,
you know?
Yeah.
Well for sure.
Judo,
I don't,
I wonder how much Jujitsu has changed
since then to now because obviously um,
and putting so much emphasis on the
ground,
the Brazilians really refined all the
submission techniques to a razor sharp
edge and really changed a lot of the
original setups and the way people enter
into submissions.
I would love to see what it used to look
like.
Even that's funny because if you look at
like some old judo,
like causing judo,
where they have is very ground oriented.
Those guys do leg locks where it's like
you see these Japanese guys from the
1920s like lock in each other and you're
like,
oh my God,
this.
So the stuff that today's hot,
some of these guys were doing and it
probably wasn't as refined,
but it was like men,
they weren't doing it.
That's catch wrestling.
Catch wrestling was all about leg locks.
They were leg locking when,
you know,
the Americans were really into Brazilian
Jujitsu and stuff.
Is this,
I woulda got here,
Jamie 1,608 d the history of Jujitsu or
Yo Wara Huh?
Wow.
The,
the dressed up in like,
um,
I Kito Kimonos with the big flowing
pants and the guy's like doing some
weird sort of wrist lock.
Go,
go,
stop scrolling.
Go right up there.
What was it like?
Yeah,
it looks like,
yeah,
he's the race looking and getting the,
yeah.
Yeah.
Interesting.
And then the other one,
it looks like he's got,
it looks like it's setting up a full
Nelson.
Yeah.
He has a half an less on one side and
he's got an under hook and the other
side of that,
you know,
but I'm really going to spin around and
slam him right on his face.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Um,
that they have,
you get to look at it and these images
or they were just trying to figure out
like what's the best way to manipulate
the body.
It's just amazing to me how much of it
came from Japan.
Yup.
I mean Japan,
so many interesting techniques and that
one area,
it was so vital and so important when it
came to the development of martial arts
in Japan.
Is that weird?
Like a distillery story between China
and Japan is very similar to ancient
Greece and ancient Rome.
You know,
a lot of the developments came from
Greece.
A lot of the developments came from
China,
but then both the Roman and the Japanese
took those ideas and then ran with it
and systematize them,
gave them a lot more of a structure or
gave them,
made them way easier to learn and to
teach and then popularize them as a
result.
And it was like,
Yep,
now this stuff works.
It's a lot easier to,
to that they brought it to other
countries.
Yeah,
that was part of vision.
[inaudible] was not a nationalist.
He did not have these Japan,
fuck you,
everybody else.
He had this idea of like you need is
universal brotherhood of mankind,
so we need to bring our staff so that
everybody can benefit from it.
And,
and so he said,
yeah,
he's on people over door.
That's amazing.
There was even an idea that followed
because he did a three part series on in
history,
on fire about till the Roosevelt,
because he was just such a crazy
motherfucker,
right?
He's like,
no,
why?
Maybe come precedent.
That's the wildest dude out there and he
even like 1905 nine somewhere right
around there.
He had a guy sent by Cano that taught
judo to the United States precedent and
so it was,
well,
it was one of the very first Americans
ever to to learn some Judah.
He was such an important precedent.
Man.
If it wasn't for him,
we wouldn't have the national public
lands we have to them.
He was awesome.
He's the,
you know,
I generally speaking when you're talking
about us,
but I sit in is like different degrees
of what I don't like.
It's like,
okay,
I hate this guy,
mildly hate this guy.
I'd really hate this guy.
Total result was one of those dudes who,
right.
I mean there's some stuff that he did
then say they are like,
Oh shit.
Okay that it wasn't so good,
but so much of it is awesome.
What did he say that you don't like?
Well,
I mean you got to give him a pass for
when he leaves,
but he of course,
the,
his idea about race,
copper to what we would consider a cool
today.
Yeah.
Not the,
he had some pretty heavyweight.
He started a lot more racist than the
end that,
so I also giving credit for that.
For being adaptive.
Yeah,
very adoptable.
Then cooling direct guard.
But clearly some of his writings was
pretty freaky and,
and also he's one of the guy who just
never swear war.
He didn't like,
you know,
he's like,
or yes,
venture.
Right?
Yeah.
The Art of Jujitsu is worth more in
every way.
Then all of our athletics combined,
President Theodore Roosevelt 1905 I
agree.
Yup.
I agree.
Me and Teddy Roosevelt,
same page.
Good.
You even seem like he lost sight in one
eye while he was president because of
sparring.
Too hard.
Really go heat way to hire because he
barks all the time.
Right.
So he goes,
he last division.
Yep.
He lost vision in one eye.
Somebody's thumb.
The president probably mother fucker.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's gangster as president until a lot
of big game hunting too.
Man,
that guy went all over the world.
He did wild guy really when you think
about it.
But my favorite ever was about a story.
Speaking of bad ass is a,
in 1912 he's running for president again
as a third party candidate out of which
was cool in itself,
right.
Because he was challenging both the
Republican and Democrats.
He is in his car waving to the people
and somebody shooting for just a few
feet away,
just straight in his chest.
But at the time he had these a 50 page
of speech,
he had better pay or to,
so he had all the written notes in his
pocket.
He had his glass case in his pocket.
So the bullet did hit him,
but it was low down by going through the
glass case and the speech.
Yeah,
but still you just took a bullet to the
chest,
you're bleeding and stuff.
And so everybody's like,
oh my God,
we need to take him to the hospital and
the Roosevelt coffee,
any sand.
He said that there's no blood coming
out.
So he said,
okay,
my lungs are in tough.
They haven't been pierced,
so what are you talking about hospital?
I got a speech to give,
so he shows up,
we tee shirt covered in blood,
and he goes like,
yeah,
I'm ladies and gentlemen.
I don't know if you know I've been shot,
but it takes more than these two Kilo
Bull Moose and then deliver 90 minute
speech before several of his attendance.
Fine.
I'd be like,
can we now go to the hospital please?
They're like,
okay,
sure.
Now we can go.
What was the hospital back then?
You'd probably be better off not going
to rub the dead chicken on your whole
probably.
What could they possibly do to fix that
back then?
You know?
Wow.
Yeah,
I mean hard times,
right?
Hard times,
great hard men,
soft times create a lot of the weak
bitches we're seeing flopping around our
streets today.
That's exactly what of the things that
Roosevelt Hammer song over and over.
He had this whole idea of the strenuous
life,
the idea that,
you know,
he came from an upper class super
elitist background and he realize,
and a lot of people back then works in,
you know,
our kids are going to be enough to be a
bunch of Williams because they are too
pampered.
And so he solution since he was a
teenager was boxing,
wrestling,
hunting,
just these very tough mainly things.
And so that's what he thrived on this
whole idea of like,
yeah,
you need to,
he had a great quote about you have to
keep your barbaric things,
things in order to go along with
civilization.
And that was like,
that's perfect.
You know,
that's like the best of both words.
And yeah,
that guys,
I had a blast style.
I mean I knew about him,
but once you get to do a series,
you really need to know your stuff in
and out.
So it was so fun to study his life
because it was a stand out like that.
And The Times that he did and the early
19 hundreds I mean really,
really pretty significant.
That's,
that's actually one of the things that I
dig about that I do a little different
from the way Dan approaches hardcore
history.
Dan tend to look at things from the big
picture,
you know,
he's telling you big picture stories and
I loved that.
But I also like jam pinning too.
I like biographies.
I like sometimes telling the story of
this one guy and what he really meant to
be this individual in this story.
And so I did,
you know,
I did to the Roosevelt,
I did one on crazy horse.
I did one on [inaudible] painter.
We're talking about catch up.
I've got to catch up as long as the
blind that you was dig.
I had did the Jack and Jill on some,
you know,
the first black heavyweight champion.
He's so fun.
You know my favorite Jack Johnson story
is he got pulled over for speeding up
the cars and the story,
you know,
it's my dues.
That's exactly,
I was telling that Carolyn the,
Oh,
I've got to do Jack Johnson and he said,
ward by ward what you say.
And he said,
you know,
that's my favorite.
Jack Johnson started.
I wonder if that was,
well,
tell the story.
So what happened was he gets pulled over
in [inaudible] state,
I believe it was George at the time when
you know,
being at Texas might've been Georgia.
Everybody has their,
you know,
not many people at the Paris and Jack
Johnson was one of the guys who love is
fast cars and he was speeding.
So they pull him over and the cop is
like,
hey boy,
this is going to cost you.
You owe me $50 and you know back then
you could pay your ticket on the spot in
cash than Jack on some police cop,
Catia,
I would start,
it is a hundred and a coffee.
He's like,
I don't have changed for that kind of
money.
And he's like,
no,
no.
Two hours from now I'm going to be
driving back the same way and they're
going to be doing the same speed.
So I'm just paying you hand.
I hope that was true.
I refuse to listen to anyway,
that tells me any different,
fuck that story about the Victorian.
Yeah.
Table ignore or give you that one.
I'll let you take that one,
but I'm,
I want to keep that Jack Johnson story.
Well,
there are too many that he did in public
feats,
that persona to thing,
like if he eats know it's that way.
Well is it,
he was the dude with 1905 1906 around
that time it was making a living as a
black guy,
beating up white guys in their ink and
sleeping with white women who,
and he figured it out.
He did it and he didn't get lynched.
Amazingly enough.
Amazing.
Yeah.
I mean,
how do they keep that from happening?
How did they keep that Guy Alive?
I mean with the racism that existed back
then,
I mean,
you're talking about just a few decades
after slavery.
He,
he,
he's,
Byron's were born in slavery.
He was the first generation of somebody
who was not born in his live in,
in his family.
And you know,
they say that at times he did sleep with
a gun under his pillow.
They did say,
yeah,
well you're amazing.
How the fuck could you,
I mean,
how could you sleep back?
Imagine being a black guy at the turn of
the century back then,
who was just in the kind of racism.
I don't even think we can comprehend to
it.
It's something good.
Think about the civil rights movement
and the,
the,
all the,
you know,
the hosing of the protests and stuff
like that.
That was 60 years later.
That's the mellow stuff.
That's everyone.
It chilled out by then.
There was,
um,
Taylor Roosevelt,
that booker t Washington for dinner,
the White House,
and he was the first time ever done a
black guy was officially invited for
dinner at the White House right after he
had the dinner.
There was such a backlash,
like sense,
uh,
some of the Santa sort on the side.
I would start,
I flipping out and I forget the exact
words,
but one of the guys at one point said,
you know,
after the precedent did the sing,
we are gonna now have to lean shut
thousand and Garcia our state to put
them back in their place.
And you're like,
I'm sorry.
Try that again.
That's the u s senate from the Endi was
patty tick.
Sap did.
I was just,
I will know the La Times about Jack
Johnson said,
you know,
why didn't Jim jefferies key limb that
brutal based that you know,
the staff that you read,
the quotes are like,
come on,
somebody must have made it up because
they couldn't be dare racist.
He was in the La Times.
God will year was that a Johnson won the
title I believe in 1908,
I want to say.
And uh,
but all,
even in the previous year she was making
a reputation for being a bad ass
fighter.
It's amazing that 110 years ago we were
that fucked up.
That's so recent.
Well,
when,
uh,
when he had the fight with Jim Jefferies
was the old undefeated.
Why champion,
you know,
because when he won the title and then
it started,
they started throwing a bunch of white
guys,
a team that he crashed as the great
white hope.
Then eventually the writer,
Jac loan don't started this campaign to
bring Jim Jeff phase the undefeated why
champion back from retirement to redeem
the white race.
And Jim [inaudible] was a beast,
right?
It was a whole coffee man strong and
knocked out all of his opponents,
but he'd been retired for a while and so
he comes back,
they have this fight in Reno,
Nevada on July 4th,
1910 by the time the fight is over,
injector on some crashes him and wins
the title,
you know,
defends his title easy.
There are riots in 25 states in 50
different cities and by the time the
riots are done,
like dozens of people are dead because
Jack Johnson and I'd beat and Jim
Jefferies and what are they listening to
it over the radio.
At the time it wasn't like they had like
telegraph news,
the sand to the newspaper and there will
be a guy in this public square screaming
Johnson just landed and left took.
That's how they did it.
Wow.
That is crazy.
[inaudible] San Fransisco,
they had a,
they had to box there,
said he knocked the news of sent by
telegraphs before what was going on.
Everybody just walked around back then.
I mean look at these people just
wandering through the streets.
Even like when there was a a fight going
on,
like there's no announcers so there's no
commentary,
right?
Yes.
It sit down and watch no TV.
There's no,
no,
this is,
this is Jeffery's training is clearly gy
star in training camp then yeah,
here it is.
There it was.
And back then you could clean shallot
inboxing,
which was kind of Jack Johnson and
style.
He would get like double bicep control.
Usually he would
keep you there so you can't hate him.
And then once in a while he would break
free,
throw an upper cut and go back to
Clinton did.
He was fucking jacked for the time.
Yeah.
When you think about this time like
people back then,
you know there was no fucking
supplements.
Yeah.
They barely knew how to work out.
Exactly.
You know,
even when he's punching like his
technique is very different.
Yup.
They and also they had a be really
concerned about breaking their hands
because they were fighting with these
little tiny ass gloves and basically
like mma gloves with thumbs in some of
these fights,
like they were scheduled for insane
sinks.
Like,
I believe this one was scheduled for 45
rounds.
How many rounds it go?
Uh,
I think 15 fourth at 2:00 PM in July,
Nevada.
And they're handled and 10 degree
weather.
It's like wow,
who does that?
You know?
Hundred and 10 degree weather in fucking
Reno.
Yup.
Crazy hat on.
Everyone in the crowd.
They were in the same hat.
That's a good point Jamie.
Look,
they all wore those goofy ass fucking
hats.
Like why did everybody like I want to
look,
just like say want to wear a nice hat
while I watched our white race sex hade
like how many black people in the
audience [inaudible] you can count on
that yet.
They say that the band before Jack and
Jones came onto the rig shortly before
they announced the,
when he came on,
the band was playing these popular songs
of the time called old coons look alike
to me.
Wow.
That's right before he comes on.
So this is like one of those things
where like people are hoping that the
bad guy loses.
So there millions of people are paying
attention because they want Jack Johnson
to lose.
It's not that they are hoping a good
fight takes place and let's see who
wins.
They wanted to get this guy off the
throne.
This was in tvm about boxing.
These was about race.
Yeah.
Real kind of amazing.
Then I went as long as it did.
Yup.
And here they are.
They're in the 13th round.
You gotta be a different kind of human
to fight with those little gloves for as
many rounds as these people fought.
Yep.
No,
it was geisler fascinating stuff.
Or who else have you covered,
uh,
on,
on your podcast?
Biographies?
Let me think that you really like,
it changed the way you feel about them.
Checking Johnson was awesome.
I had so much fun studying though.
And you know,
all the biographies done or some of my
favorites.
He unforgivable blackness.
I,
that was the first thing when I started
the research,
that was where I started.
I started watching the Ken Burns
documentary,
which was great.
And that kind of gave me the basics of
the story.
And I'm like,
okay,
I see where all of you to going now go
back through the tedious stuff or three
devotee damn book about him and plugging
all the information and stuff.
But yeah,
the documentary is great.
Yeah,
I love that one.
So who else have you done that really
like kind of stood out for you?
So the big ones have been a crazy horse
caravan.
Joe Theodore Roosevelt,
Jack Johnson.
Those are the biographies I've done.
Crazy horse is a fast
anyone.
Are they still doing that crazy South
Dakota sculpture of him?
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know.
I'll put him to do it forever because
the guy who started a project is long
dead,
so right.
Second,
they depend on private money.
So they are not really moving a tiny
kind of,
so isn't it kind of fucked because there
was no pictures of crazy horse.
We literally have no idea what I looked
like.
Nope.
None whatsoever.
If you're doing this,
you're just essentially like guessing.
I mean,
they could use your face completely.
Yeah.
I think they should use my face.
Why not the,
but yeah,
that's a better story right there.
Cause that was a guy,
he kind of a,
it's almost like watching a Maryville
thing about wolverine.
You know,
he has this super power that guy was a
beast in warfare,
but everyone he loved around him died
and so you'll have these kind of tragic
figure off the guy was a beast.
But for all his powers he can protect
the ones they love.
Well he fought naked and cut little
pieces of his body off.
Like he cut chunks of flesh off all over
his body.
Like his entire body was like a mosaic
of scars.
There was um,
yeah it was even before like a couple of
weeks before the battle of the little
bighorn.
It is the famous bath towel with Costa
and doto flood and there was a 16 bul.
One of the other main Lakota leaders
participated in his sundance and one of
the things they did was kind of cut like
50 flesh all fitting Oni Sharm where do
you kind of cut these like pin size
needle of your flesh but steel.
And the whole point is to go into this
trance partially from the pain,
partially from dehydration,
peripherally prayer and Dolo fit and the
stories that sitting bull then at this
vision that they were going to be
attacked.
The troops were going to reach their
camp,
but they were going to get crushed.
And so the vision was even at a bath
towel shortly thereafter and sitting
bull was like,
yeah,
this wasn't,
this wasn't close to our camp division
is they are attacking our camp.
And that's when supposedly the whole
little bighorn thing,
that's why they were feeling kind of
like we can handle it.
We're good with this.
She wish she knew if that was true.
The whole,
you know,
vision.
Yeah.
Dares to think about that kind of a
culture where the stories that they say
like a lot of the time in order to get a
reputation for being the guy who can
say,
hey,
I had a vision and people actually
believe you,
you need to have proven something along
the way.
You need to have,
cause I mean,
anybody can say I had a visa on the end.
He's like,
yeah,
that's great.
Show us.
Are you,
can you now see that dude?
Yes or no.
If you can't shut up,
you're just not losing 18.
What can you say?
I have a vision and then it comes true.
Exactly as you said.
Well in that case people are like,
okay,
now we're paying attention.
Next time you have a vision police
stylus.
But if you say,
I had division that these happen and
nothing happened,
everybody's like,
shut up.
You're just,
I just wish we knew that like him going
into a state of mind where it was almost
dying because you're like,
what was that a a man called horse of
movie where they do that thing that
barb's through your nipples and hang you
from the ceiling.
That's a sundance.
I've been actually too,
because that was illegal for a really
long time.
Right.
Then they brought it back in the open in
the 1970s,
and I've been to,
I think seven sun dances rarely do that.
You've watched people get suspended by
their nipples that usually don't get
suspended and is non nipples is uh,
just the um,
yeah,
the,
the chest muscle,
well they don't go under the muscle is
just kin but they go up on top and a
day.
So they usually don't get suspended but
they dance attach we there is a rope to
the tree and then when they want a bit
of clues they just rip right through.
And you know,
you've got like these quarter size,
the scar I auto fit.
And which you know,
when you think about the whole idea of
sacrifice is something that they do in
all the religions pretty much to be
friendly degrees.
You know,
back in the day animal sacrifice was
huge.
That was one of the sinks and you know,
these guys have it as a,
you shed the blood cause that's your
energy.
That's the one thing.
And that will give strength to your
prayers and all of that stuff.
But yeah,
first time I ever saw it I was like,
Holy Shit,
this is intense.
This is probably also something to that
where they're trying to put people
through something to make them stronger.
There definitely is that aspect and that
is like,
yeah,
this is not something that somebody does
Willy Nilly.
Like,
Oh,
I'm going to sundance tomorrow.
He's like,
no,
you don't mess around it.
Now that this ritual,
in fact,
it's probably to strengthen their
resolve and make their better warriors
just by having experienced such a
horrific ritual,
ritual,
practice ripping,
meet off your tits.
The m one started a day,
say legit.
It looks legit.
Looks like a white guy thought,
I don't know.
Yeah,
it looks like a guy who was pretty
annoying.
So it looks like the betties on Venice
beach right now.
The,
there's a story that they say about can
see yours.
And then when he was a kid to toughen
him up,
he said,
dad,
uh,
had killed a turtle,
that they were going to it.
But the story goes that the turtle heart
keeps beating after it's dead for awhile
and carved out with the third girl and
pull out this still beating heart and
gave it to crazy horse tweet.
Heathrow and yeah.
Raw Turtle Heart.
I don't recommend it.
He'll be team.
Yeah.
We were all kind of fucking diseases you
get from turtle hearts.
But as a,
I would say cook that well done.
Right.
That's the only way to have seven good
third heart.
Yeah.
I mean what kinds of parasites and shit.
Her and turtles,
turtles eat everything.
Right.
But that's also what's funny is like
when you think about like walls or you
think about people who live super close
to nature,
they could eat stuff that if we try
today were dead in 30 seconds and they
were fine.
I think that it's speeding.
Yep.
Googled it.
And it came up right away.
Wow.
Turtle heart and just going off.
Did you hear about that guy who just got
fired?
I think it was in Iowa.
He was a school teacher.
He fed a snapping turtle.
A puppy in the middle of the class.
What the hell?
No,
I did not hear.
Yeah.
He,
uh,
he's currently suspended.
That's what I think.
Yeah.
This guy a,
he had done some other dark shit in
class before.
It is teacher investigator for feeding
puppies to snapping turtles.
It's cool.
Go,
go see the image of the guy in the
beginning of the article again.
They go back to the,
the video and pause in his face.
Cool.
There he is out.
Fuck.
Why hasn't it shows face again right
there.
Let me see his face like goofy Prek.
Awesome.
It looks like a fucking complete psycho.
Yeah.
There he is.
Look at him.
Oh,
well,
you know,
if you leave a puppy,
will the snapping to hurdle.
He will eat.
He will.
I'll show Hoshyar.
Okay.
Don't tell your mom.
Yeah,
don't do that deck.
We have animals that we like more than
other animals.
Yeah.
That's a fact.
That's,
and we like poppies a whole lot more
than we like those dirty fucking stinky
hardheaded turtles.
Yeah.
Leavers.
Ari Parker.
Is he alone?
Oh,
I like it.
Yeah.
That's how it is.
Some item,
we'll start.
Cool.
There's fucking them.
We have a profound hypocrisy,
fine by me.
Don't you think?
Do you,
uh,
you're probably more aware of that than
the average person because of your study
of history.
I mean,
the,
the hypocrisy of the human race are most
exposed by going over them and the
washing these patterns repeat themselves
over and over and over again.
Yeah.
No,
I mean it's a,
the,
that's why to me,
I'm completely fascinated by the inner
workings of the human mind because the
way that people can spin stories to
themselves to justify stuff that in
another context will be going see
they're completely insane.
That kind of goes back to that like the
average person is a flag in the wind
that can go anyway.
You know,
how ridiculous is it that like 200 years
ago,
if you tell people this lavery
overwhelming majority of people would be
like,
of course slavery school.
What's wrong with at it?
Kind of a free car.
You,
your anti slavery,
are you insane?
And if you say today,
you know,
you're going to have like 0.01% of the
population would be cool with it.
And,
and yet we're the same people,
200 years have gone by,
but suddenly what was completely normal
at one point is considered batshit crazy
today.
Yeah.
It is weird.
It's weird.
And it's,
and it's constantly changing,
you know,
constantly evolving and it doesn't
always need to make sense.
It just,
this is what's the new thing?
Yeah.
This is the new way of being and you
know,
there's always a small percentage of our
population that's not going to go along
with the program that's going to be
like,
no,
this is a stupid idea.
But,
but the average is just going to go
wherever critical mass is steel team.
They are going to go with it.
Yeah.
Listen man,
I've got to wrap this up,
but uh,
always a beautiful thing to talk to you.
My brother.
You'd go checkout Daniela [inaudible]
podcast is called history on fire.
It's available on itunes and a year on
all the social media things.
A deep allele on twitter,
aud below on instagram as well.
Instagram,
the only one I don't do.
You don't do that at all?
No,
they're on facebook.
So it's shallow assholes like me.
All right.
Thank you brother.
Appreciate it,
man.
Thank you so much.
Sure.